You
I will miss you it'll be actually painful um not being able to stream because I realize
every awaken moment I just want to stream because I was gonna stream earlier and I'm
like no I don't let me just pace myself um my voice is a little shot as you can hear
uh and maybe the vacation meta will pay off I don't know I'm not I'm not as
I'm not as cool as Emmy in terms of um she had a lot of stuff uh that was going on in her
I do have some shorts I am gonna work on a video an ASMR video for you guys to listen to
you before I'm gone um who's gonna run Wonderland all she beats afk strawnee will
Johnny is is my second hand second hand woman
um yeah I almost stream Hades yesterday but I'm like I need to not I need to pace myself I
need to just stream when I'm going saying I'm going to stream because otherwise I will get burnt
out I'm not don't worry I'm not burnt out it just like if I know if I try to stream like literally
like eight hours like I'm not strongy I can't stream like 12 hours a day every day it's very
difficult um but yeah strawnee strawnee will be in charge
I still have so much to do to prepare I don't even have I might have to go ask my parents if I can
borrow one of their suitcases because I'm like I don't even have a suitcase because I don't like to
travel I haven't traveled to see my grandparents um alone since I was 16 and I'm very anxious
going to an airport by myself um but you know I just I haven't seen my grandparents in almost
like two years and I'm trying and then thankfully because of you guys I'm able to afford a ticket
so I can fly over so thank you for that um strawnee left with Wonderland oh boy um
but yeah I'm just a whole 40 yeah it's been a whole 40 years since I've seen my grandparents that
are in their 120s um I'm boomy what's up cancel
here's your hi what are you doing oh you're reaching out you're telling me to get off the
computer I feel like boomy nose when I'm really tired I also don't feel good it's my fucking heart
it's important all day if I haven't eaten a lot it's only only having the applesauce and the
two bites of like rice um yeah it's just like I don't it's gonna be because it's like it's not
like a round trip it's like there's a connect there's like a layover and I'm worried that like
I'll miss flight or what have you but what the kitties my parents are gonna be watching them um
yeah my parents will be watching them and then I have the cat cam so I can keep an eye um
yeah still flying I'm very nervous uh
uh
and I also haven't been to that airport in 40 years so I don't know where the fuck I'll be going
so me can you please just like sit there thank you
um yeah I don't I think that was the last time I flew too was when I saw my grandparents
that time I know it's been longer no oh no because I flew up here that's a lie
they flew up here the last few years um yeah I just like you guys know like I'll be tweeting
like every friday I'll I'll probably do like a um
uh an audio but not I don't know if I'll be able to get away with anything
ooh alternative but um I don't think I will be in the mood to do that
I was flying prena oh it was great it was amazing now I have to take off my shoes I didn't have to
do that before um I also get really bad ear pain being on an airplane and that's why
I don't like flying the last two the last place I traveled to you know yeah I drove
I drove to Canada with friends that was fun you drove to Montreal
and then I've driven to New York before with my parents
yeah I also have to figure out I don't even know because like
I don't know I've asked my parents if they're gonna drive me to the airport
I don't know I have to make sure my grandparents are my aunt because I have also
have aunt and uncles they live down there so I'm gonna try to see
firm yeah yeah TSA gets feet for free yeah I have I get really bad ear pain because one of
my eustachian tubes is kind of sort of blocked because of my arthritis in my neck because of
inflammation and all that other shit I've told you that before um so my ears really hurt so I'm
gonna buy like a pack of gum hope for the best my mom has flown a lot she flew a lot for work um so
she has a lot of she's already written me like a lot of advice um I it's so weird because I feel
like a little kid again I feel like I am 16 15 again I forget how old I was flying to go see
my grandparents and I was terrified back then and I'm terrified but they're older now they can't
really fly so it's not it's better for me to travel rather than them
hi I'm sorry I'm sorry I missed you guys too but you know like I'll tweet a bunch
have shorts I have an ASMR I think I'm gonna do like a ear cleaning ASMR um
I'm trying to think I might I'm debating whether or not to like pre-record like some
Hades gameplay or something um just so you guys like have a video that goes up and it's me playing
or maybe meet just like a totally different game um like I'll play something else like a
do a little like pseudo playthrough style thing and just do a quick like one shot of something
and have that up as well just so you guys don't get too lonely um I see you think of a game to play
so if you have any suggestions let me know yeah don't worry it's I won't I don't leave for eight
days I don't I don't leave till the 18th y'all that's all indie playthrough yeah don't worry I
just want to tell you guys in advance I didn't want to come first talk to be like surprise I'm
not gonna be around but it's like it's halfway through the week so you still it won't feel
too much like a week I don't think because like I'm leaving on I think a Friday or Thursday and
I'm coming back on a Tuesday so it's just like kind of you guys almost won't have me for like a
weekend or something Hoonipop no I want to play Hoonipop on blue twitch with no sensors um but
yeah I just didn't I don't want you guys to stress um I'll probably just be like tweeting from the
plane just like screaming in my head like just maybe I'll have a twitter space and be talking to
myself like a crazy person next to the I got a window seat on the way there but I'm in the middle
on the way back which I'm gonna hate I hope I'm not sitting next to weird people because I will
try to outweard them so that I feel safer
uh
you know getting good credit how about what I missed something
I understand why there's no advance if your child is just moving safely yeah me too
I just hope like my worst I like again you know OCD you always like think of the worst so I'm just
like the plane's gonna go down uh something about I'm gonna lose my luggage this is gonna happen
this is gonna happen um so like my mind goes like a million miles an hour
definitely gonna need to I'm gonna charge up my switch um so I can play it on the plane and stuff
I also have my laptop I could bring my laptop with me
but I don't have like a portable mic to plug in because then I would just like png
like stream and be like hi grandparents um I love you I'm gonna be locked in my room
at like 12 at night and if you hear screaming don't worry about it but my grandparents would
be absolutely mortified if they heard me streaming because they are very christian
and if they heard me swear I'd feel so bad
if I could tell you the funny shit my my grandparents say because they're so christian
I love them to death though
reminds me of a lady going I've seen people talk about how they used to next to a hot person
in an airplane so if I haven't had that her friend thought she doesn't know she's the hot person
oh I hope I'm the hot person flight simulators help you yeah I like I'm not scared of flying
I'm just scared of things out of my control like when I can't control a situation
that it frightens me I prefer safety start one of those prayer circles they just exercise me
how do they feel if they saw a sexy muppet um honestly I don't think they would worry about it
that much because my grandparents really love them up it's like my grandmother especially
I think they have like all the things on like DVD and uh they probably think be like oh this is
like Miss Piggy or something and it has boobs I don't know
man I need to ask you I'm going to the beach soon do you want me to keep my
even in the water no you don't have to wear it if you don't have to wear it in the water
um I'm not if it can you can wear it in the water then that's cool but like again um
I don't want you to like break it or lose it
just know that if you do it like tightly a market leaves this from me
this is why you are dumb don't like to lose the control oh yeah that's a good point
yeah I hate losing control I generally do if I can't control a situation I get very upset
so where am I it's gonna be weird not having she be holding on to my leash
yeah I'm passing the reins over to Strani so she'll be she's she's educated in that
I've already handed over your keys to her uh to your cages so you'll be fine
mercy will also be keeping an eye um on the hair members that are trapped in my cage
because she is also knowledgeable at cages but don't worry you guys will be well loved
and well taken care of make sure mercy feeds you don't worry um yeah I'm gonna miss my cat so much
I remember my every time I see my grandmother she like makes fun of me because the last time I was
there um and this is when I had um Reina and Solea Solea being Reina's sister before she passed away
and I was there so I was I was staying with my grandparents for a month um but I left like
I think like a couple days or a week early because I just miss Reina and Solea so much
so it's literally gonna be so hard for me to be away from all my cats it's I don't know
I don't know how people do it like often if I could travel with them I would
I think the only cat that would be okay with traveling would be
actually none of them Fia's been kind of scared lately for some reason every time I open the door
she like runs and I'm like did someone like come into my apartment like a maintenance guy when
I wasn't here again and like scare the shit out of my cat like why are she scared every time I open
the door it's really weird um but otherwise I would say I would would have said Fia Reina actually
might chill Reina will just like really hey what's up Reina's doing well she's healing up well I was
looking at her but um if I could show you guys the before and after of what her the gash on her
fucking leg looked like um from her anal gland rupturing you guys would be absolutely horrified
because it looked like she got shot right next to her booty cheek um but she it's literally uh
scabbed over now it looks really good she's doing really well she's very I was recording
video this morning of her playing I'll probably post it um she's been yeah she's sleeping on a chair
I'm like turning around um and losing tracking because I'm looking at her she's across the room
um and then yeah boomy boomy's you know a menace as per usual nothing you're there
cats are intuitive you know these moving countries are a little more than usual things
happen yeah um
yeah Reina I feel like Reina I'm really worried about Reina because Reina is definitely like
imprinted on me um my voice is cracking a little bit because I'm sad talking about it um so I'm
gonna miss her a lot because she's my cat but thankfully she also loves my mom a lot so but
she sees my mom she's gonna be really happy um she loves hanging out with my mom when my mom came
over last she uh she was like really excited to see her and it was it's funny how you like is my
she hadn't seen Reina in like probably a couple months like quite like six months and my mom's
like she's forgotten me and I'm like no she hasn't I've had her since she was a kid and she knows
anywhere um but yeah she's really great she's healing my grandparents have pets no my grandparents
have never had pets because they're the type of people that think animals are meant to be outside
at all times um that was funny the first time my grandpa so these are my Haitian grandparents
um so they they also have you know that that they have like Haitian accents um
like my grandfather almost like it's more like a french accent and uh so back like I remember
a couple years ago when my grandparents first saw Reina Reina used to be a really fat cat unless
until she recently lost a lot of weight because of her age and she just can't like she used to be
like like 17 pounds I'm not even kidding you we I will post pictures of when she was very large
and so my grandfather saw her the first time she like walked out from like uh this is when I
lived at my parents house and then she walked out from like behind a wall or something and my
grandfather goes oh look at her she is pregnant wow she's what a beautiful cat you're gonna have
beautiful kittens and I'm like poppy no she's not pregnant she's not pregnant
yeah Reina was a thicker I still thick um I used to I used to I used to call her Miss Chonk
she'll she'll always be fat to me even though she's like normal cat size now
yeah he definitely fat shamed her um but yeah I haven't even told my grandparents like I quit
my job yet so it's gonna be kind of awkward having that conversation my grandfather texted me yesterday
he's like hey how's it going I can't wait blah blah blah and I'm just like it's going great I can't
wait to see you soon because I know I like they are they're very traditional um
like I know they were kind of upset that I didn't go to college because my grandfather was gonna
pay for my college until but then I went a little um I took a gap year and then he didn't but yeah
it's a whole fake thing um they don't know what I do now only my parents do and some and like two
my two best friends all of in Salem have you guys uh I've mentioned to you often um my grandparents
don't know my former employer knows because I was just like yeah fuck you guys I'm gonna go be a big
streamer no I didn't say that uh they don't have old country value oh yeah um it's like boy or
kettlebell that's cute yeah the oh they only want I never take it personally they only ever want
what's best for me um if I told them anything that I did they'd probably be absolutely mortified
I'd be like she's living in sin um yeah they won't be I'll probably skirt around the topic and be
like oh you know like because I remember when I tweeted that tweet like oh what do I tell people
that I do I'm just gonna be like I uh work for a startup social media company but I'm under
NDA so I can't say anything and then they'll be like oh okay and I rather they won't like they
won't usually when I'm there I make them talk a lot so uh probably Morgan
okay I'll tell you one funny thing that my grandfather has said
so my grandparents were here last they um they came why did they come for did I think
they did they come from like one of my parents anniversaries or something and my mom flew
them up as a surprise I think I think so I can't remember so I'm going and my grandparents were
staying um with my with my family for about like a week week and a half or two weeks I can't really
remember and so my grandfather's like oh I want to go get some and my grandfather's the type he's
always like wear slacks he's always was like wearing a polo he's very well-dressed man he used to be
a Spanish teacher in Haiti and um he uh so we're looking for pants for him and with my grandmother
just me him and my grandmother and he's just like looking at all these like slacks and he's like
why are all these pants so skinny what they're what is this these cockscrew pants they're
trying to look at my back sides I cannot believe them it is the homosexuals they want to see my
back sides and they want to grab my back side I'm like poppy no I don't think I don't think the
gays want anything to do with you he's like you never know you never know what they want I'm like
poppy please remind you like my my my grandparents don't know also that I'm pansexual either I'm not
there's no need to tell like that's this person to me I don't they don't know but I think I think
it would be very funny if I was just like I said right there and then I'm like you know
it would have been funny yeah you like my accent
yeah I'm like I don't think nobody wants to look and it's like and this and this happened later
because we went shopping and he brought it up later to my parents because my parents asked him
when we had a lot of other family over because like my family's all over the place and we all
like came to my parents house and and like my parents family friends from their church and stuff
and my grandfather is telling the story of this really short pants that's really tight
skinny pants like skinny jeans and stuff and like skinnier slacks like they're really like
whatever I don't really know how what they're called um and he's telling it to the group
as we're like at my parents house around the fire and my mom is just looking mortified
she's trying not to laugh so hard because like my parents my parents don't like my parents a lot
more lax but my grandparents are hardcore like values like traditional uh biblical values my
parents a little bit more lax so my mom is just like like redacted redacted it's fine don't worry
about it like you did I hope you found better pants anyways is anybody you want some uh potato
salad is anybody
I think my family has gotten worse this time to be these last liver when I was a kid
oh I just take yeah my parents were a lot more conservative and now they just like really don't
give a shit anymore um I don't really care either way I just I don't have the energy to hate
that's not my problem I don't care um
that's my grandparents my parents are chill my parents are chill
my parents are very chill um they kind of just do their own thing
my mom is the type of uh Christian woman where she
she says oh as long as nobody's hurting anyone
and people are just showing each other with love and respect
um that's all she could ever ask for
hating is too much effort for nothing exactly I just don't I just don't have the energy
even like people like really disagree with me or like have a totally different world view I'm
just like I don't care speaking of which if you don't follow my alt twitter I said to read
and this is why I have this mindset is because of this book I read the four agreements um
because I sometimes I get I used to get so caught up with what people thought of me
and how they spoke to me and how they did this this and that and like that book helped me so much
I highly recommend it um and it's it's written in such a
like lazy way that it's like it sounds like you're just talking to someone and they're just like
you know like you got to stop assuming stuff about people because when you assume it becomes
miscommunications and like it's just it's just really funny how it's written um but I believe
it's only like eight bucks off amazon it's a very good book
I love doing that I like go XLRs like lit up very oddly whatever um
but yeah yeah yeah it's a good book I remember and I'm not you know afraid to say this um when I
was younger I was hospitalized because mental Illinois and um uh they had like flash cards of
that and then and I always I always liked because they're like kind of just like affirmations you
would say and just like what you could think about um to like kind of like improve and stuff
and then when I left in like years and years and years had passed and I could never remember
what it was called and then I walked into this random ass store and I saw the book and I was like
holy shit and I immediately bought it and it's just it's just a good book when I was my young boy
yeah it's just like uh I'm not usually like a self-help book person I think that's kind of
bullshit but I gave it a try and I liked it um my mom's very much a self-help book person
but I love that about her because then she always gives me good advice I'm like you can
consume it and then you can just give it back to me in a easier to digest format um
um I hate Illinois yeah I was like super young now I don't know what the fuck was going on um
the subtle ardent oh yeah I think my mom has that book because my mom if I could show you just like
that stack of books my mom has about self-help and nutrition because my mom loves good nutrition
um
metallic Illinois yeah normally all everybody has a little dash in metallic in Illinois um
yeah I always I'll always recommend you guys books that I think will help you or think that you
might enjoy or I'll tell you if I think they're like silly like oh read this smut book just like
how um how emi does uh I don't know mercy does mercy read I don't know I I know she reads I'm
just wondering if she reads that type of book I can't recall I think she does make a little book club
I know strongy reads a lot uh a lot of I can't remember if she reads all like nonfiction which
surprised me because she like really loves lord of the rings I like how I'm talking about mercy
and then right on my screen something she just says she tweeted something called just saying yes
and that kind of freaked me out it was like she was talking to me um because I have everyone's
notifications turned on for all the girls um I'm looking forward to more recommendations yeah yeah
I don't I'll probably yeah she likes this deck yeah she likes thrillers she likes thrillers she's in
the walls um and I read a lot of high fantasy so I might uh I haven't read any thing in a while I'm
reading that book um feather so vicious that emi recommended when she first tweeted about it
because I like bullied her into telling me I was like what she's like I don't know if you can handle
this I'm like girl I read cadence by Colleen Hoover and that is a that's that's a book for the
pin pals right there if I have any pin pals in the chat read cadence um all I'm gonna say is
cousins and an uncle
Lord Colleen Hoover is a menace fact I like Verity oh I think I might recommend Verity
to no she's like she's not she's not a super good author I'm not even I'm not saying she's a good
author by the way she I'm not saying that it's like if you just want to like read something silly
calling Hoover Hoover Hoover whatever the frick her name is is your girl um I think she would
like I think Mercy would like Verity because it is a mystery it's like a what happened to this man's
wife is the main character going crazy who I should also recommend the silent patient to Mercy but
I bet she's already read that I love I love recommending books to people it's one of my favorites
oh I feel like fantasy I read it was the speaker spear wielder trilogy oh I've never heard of that
my dad has been harassing me to read the third binding which is pretty much literally
the king killer chronicles in a different font um I like for I read like an audio I listened to
the audiobook for the first two chapters and I hated the audiobook reader that I just stopped
reading it um I think it's so funny when this person says hey they're beautiful babe and then
people in the chat respond to it okay you're all beautiful babes I just I've always thought that
was funny when that happened a book recommendation would be right before your vacay kind of a book
report stream after your vacay no I would be traumatized never say book report to me again oh
my god this shit I had to go through because it's funny I like to read a lot but I hated doing
what was assigned to me during school for book reports and stuff it was my least favorite thing
and like but I ended up like in hindsight I wish I had kind of focused more in the classics because
you know you read like Huckbury Finn while that shit and like Catcher in the Rye I kind of want
to go back and try to read those books again um because I didn't really I kind of just sped read
through them here's home school just can't relate uh explains a lot okay right a five page essay as
if you guys can tell me what to do that's funny that you think you can do that it's very cute um
but I liked I like don't get me wrong I liked English class when I could write any sort of
fiction that's why I really love my creative writing class um
I'm I just thought I was I'm debating whether or not to try to find my old email or I save stuff
and do a quick dramatic reading for you of one of my old post-by-post role plays
actually I kind of want to
uh
wait is my ipad charged because I'd rather read it off of my ipad
um
my cats love to scare me by going under the bed and jumping out at my feet
they are the monsters under my bed as my cats
they say when you pass on a new best old judge your old role play logs
sometimes they speak to your stupid questions it's not as up what does it mean I don't know
it's fucking morning bro
facts
I am plugged in
I don't care about voice messages what is happening
it's like automatically open twitter um
where is my email I have to it'll take me a moment to search
oh wait did someone someone don't know earlier by the way I thought I heard something but I
couldn't tell if it was the game or not let me look to see if we got any donos or stupas
thank you if you did by the way
nope okay cool
math can't be English and English is a math in terms of many right answers yeah there's
always
yeah math is more absolute uh I preferred English because it was you could be very ambiguous
because I'm very much like a dreamer type person
let me take the headphones off
okay let me see let me see if I just type in creative writing if anything pops up
okay
oh yep
what the fuck is about what is this
oh I remember I wrote about like a serial killer really briefly
okay I wrote this when I was like 17 you guys want to hear it
you guys want to hear it
oh my god hi rena she just like hopped on my lap as I was about to start
teenage writing
I'm gonna read this in a British accent
I hadn't meant to do it but now I have to deal with the fact that there is a dead body in
the waiting room if anyone comes in I'm screwed completely absolutely ultimately screwed
this is terrible I was just going to enjoy myself this week no slip-ups
I was going to be normal no senseless killing I had found so much for that
my head jerks to the side as I hear shoes scuffle on the tile floors and feet away
that's not good I'm running out of time my eyes glance around the cliche waiting room
a room dappled with dying house plants and pictures of smiling children they're equally
happy parents oh look over there that one's a puppy I cock my head and smile blissfully at
the splatter of scarlet that had found its way to the framed picture my smile wavered as a nurse
entered the waiting area quicker than I anticipated a clipboard in hand she was still unaware of the
fellow lying motionless on the floor in a monotone voice called out Mr. Halliday weekend I'm sorry I
have to cut you off there I'll spare you the gory details but she did fall voicelessly to the floor
with uh maybe a pen in her neck if she was lucky enough to survive it no doubt the seizure she's
having would render the brain damage she wouldn't remember me anytime soon
my ring is licking my hand and I'm trying to read what are you doing lady can you sit down
um I straightened my suit jacket also read for occasions such as these inside the clipboard
was covered in the nurse's blood but I could clearly still see one of my aliases in thick
black ink more in Halliday I like the name very much and it frustrated me now that I would have
to scrap it and get it yet another one false identities weren't particularly cheap these
days either and thinking of this caused a scowl to cross my face speaking of which I should probably
take care of my face I like how I switched from British to normal it's fine no doubt it was flecked
in my favorite color I walked hastily to the nearby bathroom the smell of sterility somewhat
dizzying even for a person like myself one who enjoys cleanliness in order ironically with a
quick gesture I opened the door and looked in the mirror and the same hazel oh see we're gonna get into
the uh the description part by the same hazel eyes same dark brown hair the same clean shaven face
even the blood dotted across it was a comforting familiarity my hand promptly reached for the
soap while its companion slumped simultaneously turned on the water and I scrubbed earnestly
thinking over my options what could I do with the two bodies bleeding out before someone will
check back eventually and I need at least 20 minutes to get my supplies in one hour to clean
everything up in another two hours to destroy your heart the bodies my lips form a thin line
want to stare into the mirror a little longer and think back I pictured the room more specifically
the corners thankfully I didn't remember any cameras I really have to have to have to take time
to erase video files and probably kill a security guard I knew DNA wasn't a problem anymore for me
I had to get to match it to a face as plain as mine I didn't have any memorable scars on my face
only my body but that's another story again I didn't I probably watched like one true crime
episode before I broke this um let me get us to the audiobook series um I rubbed my hands vigorously
with an absurd amount of paper towels before sorry this is really small font so sorry me to read
we're shoving them in a fatally small trash can and letting myself out of the bathroom
my head peeked around a few corners and it looks like no one had come through yet
I stood in the doorway of the waiting room checking my person for any signs that I had
dispatched people and found nothing incriminating besides something I could blame on a nosebleed
excuse me but the satisfied nod I opened the door to leave the
waiting room completely with a sort of flourish and fed it away
you're probably wondering who I am thinking why would someone sorry why would a person commit
something so morbid may I plead insanity not that I've ever said that none of us hello nice to
meet you my name is Nolan Nolan Aristar you've probably heard of me why the f*** I'm so f***ing
pretentious
I'm like reading this and I feel like I sound like um Heisenberg from f***ing village
oh also called the piercer
well I'm cementing the venom from my immortal
oh it's funny I wrote this before I was diagnosed with OCD you'll see why
pardon me also called the piercer pretty nifty if I do say myself giving my
given my middle name is pierce but I don't think the cops who christened me knew that
anyways drifting from the original topic you're wondering why I've done this but
sincerely sincerely I cannot tell you I tell you I cannot help it
you see I like the color red very much blood is clearly red in its purest form and I need
no eye crave to look at it touch and feel it this is all thanks to my obsessive compulsive
disorder commonly known as the abbreviation OCD this is nothing to do with OCD but it's funny
that I wrote this I'd like to stop I really would but red is just really my favorite color
it calms me it's beautiful I won't say it's art because that's so typical I strange myself from
other killers because honestly the majority of them kill for art corpses aren't majestical masterpieces
the human body's disgusting thing when twisted and deformed and truly when it's normal and you
rot on the inside from corruption or some other adjective that's more poetic
I'm not the OCD
I'll cringe from time to time at my handiwork I'll get carried away lose myself and be very
mad afterwards people need to understand how inconvenient killing a person is it's a time
consuming and it's time I can't read my own fucking email and obviously you would get into
a lot of trouble I have to take time out of my day to come and end your life which probably isn't
all rainbows and sunshine and such a place is this you're welcome you selfish prick heart sign
smiley face enough of me and my terrible explaining skills I just felt in the need to justify myself
all right all right I literally wrote heart sign smiley face by the way
I tossed my suit there's like like two more paragraphs I tossed my suit jacket
on the couch when I entered my modest and modern apartment I'm pretty sure this inspired by like
um it was inspired by like some true crime thing that I watched it was inspired by
Marceline from Adventure Time because how she drinks the color red and I think it was
inspired by like American Psycho
like all those uh I also was just very aggressive person when I was younger um
everything was just as I liked it monochrome with splashes of red I like how my that's kind
of how my outfit is um it's monochrome with splashes of red bro I was I predicting my own
am I gonna kill no I'm kidding um the only colors I can tolerate besides red are the
usual black and white colors that I am indifferent to only apples lay in the bowl on the island in
the kitchen only tomatoes were in a jar on the counter besides the sink not that everything I
eat is red that would be probably unhealthy and ridiculous I do have my limitations however you'll
find nothing orange ever anywhere in here never orange is an unsightly color that should just
go home it tries too hard to be red I don't know how some people enjoy orange juice too really
orange is an unsightly thing I know uh yeah I actually I do hate the color orange
orange is my least favorite color
so I threw some shots at orange right now but I do love orange juice so that's a lie
uh I do a little jig as I head toward the bathroom peeling off clothes as I near it
when I reach the shower I'm already completely undressed feverishly rubbing away the sense of
metal with some cinnamon soap cinnamon masks anything I'll tell you that right now I turn
my head slightly as I hear a thump somewhere from within the house confused I shut off the water
and toweled myself off before stepping out of the shower I'm not an idiot and I don't call out
who's there like a stereotypical girl in a horror movie but wrap the towel around my waist
wait already like oh no I didn't I just toweled myself well he toweled himself off
uh and wait for the sound to occur again and soon enough a moment later it does
I sigh with relief as it's not coming from within my apartment but outside the door
someone's knocking feel there she's this one
the memsie is this story so Dracula's kill who's that
Amy hate what do you mean Amy hate confirm is she like orange she's a ginger I don't
know this only applies to like the color like if it's on like it doesn't apply to ginger hair
because on Emmys I've already said Emmys model is my favorite out of everyone's
and then it goes like mercy me
actually no that's hard it'd be hard to rank all the girls models
and me mercy me
fuck because I genuinely like I like mercies and strongies even evenly um hold on
I didn't put the connection together
I meander down the Honeiro hallway somewhat lazily and finally peer through the people
just my like my luck my like on the other side it's not like I have I wrote this in great grammar
I just can't read right now on the other side is an eye trying to look through causing me to
flinch back when I look again very cautiously I see the smug look of a grizzly grizzly looking cop
he's leaning forward to knock again before I can swiftly unlock and open the door
before he can I swiftly unlock and open the door letting the cop swing at an open air then
smack me in the chest just what I wanted I let out a small squeal hey I just opened the door
might you hit me the cop was clearly flustered after this hitting a groan very fit I might add
man in a towel and took a step back oh or accident sir sorry about that this won't take long I'm
just here to ask a few questions he looked down at his shoes and pulled out a notepad and flipped
a few pages I knew it wouldn't take much to make this guy go away but still this had to be the fastest
time they spread word about clint killings it's been at least an hour and they've already brought
their search radius to my house wincing at this I leaned against the doorway trying trying
oh trying to look as huffy yet sexy as possible fire away pardon the pun I smiled widely pretending
to be happy the man was there my eagerness was an easy repellent uh well are you aware that they
have been dual killings in the area and that's it that's how it ends I remember my classmates
were like what for what happens next didn't his he just ultra instinct the door open fast enough
to get knocked in the chest well I guess if you like linger and you're like lingering your hand
they just opens it and just fucking knocks them yeah the cliffhanger let me see let me see creative
writing did you do
am I have to go like all the way back
so
the fuck was I writing Jesus Christ
what the fuck is this
oh this is some of my OCs
interesting sorry this is like I don't remember writing this I'm not reading that no
I don't want you guys to figure out how crazy I am
is that like again when I said when I joked and said that no it's not it's not one of those
it's wait is it one of those I didn't really
it was like
again as an only child I didn't have any fucking friends okay
what if you compared my creative writing to my immortal well look at
what I just read to you and then what I've read in my immortal it is not the same
peer pressure or so the wolf roleplay tweet I was trying to find the wolf roleplay one
because I remember I did like a dramatic writing of my character's death
and I love roleplay I don't know where that is though it's not showing up
I love how I left notes in the
like I like a couple years ago more than a couple years ago like like two decades ago
back when I was like 30 um I wrote like notes of like I must have reread it after like a year
and then a year after that and I was just like what the fuck is wrong with me
yeah my morals my my my magnum opus
my morals are really scary I mean a lot of it showed up for the kj somewhere
yesterday I think we're somewhere but no like like I was very
like it isn't bad like it honestly it's a normal totally normal
like I wrote like a chapter of something but it's the context behind it which makes me embarrassed
because I wrote like I have this I've told you guys I lose to dream a lot right in fact I lose to
dreams um when I woke up from my nap I was losing dreaming it was really weird um
dreams have always been really weird for me because for me when I lose to dream I usually
visualize a place and then there's like a hub after I lose to dream and it's I always end
up there there's always like a hub and then I can like I sound so it sounds fucking crazy
saying it out loud because it is it's just weird weird mind shit um but then I can go to like there's
always like there's always places in my dreams that are like always constant is how I can
say it like I don't like there's always like there's um there's I usually just call it like the hub
which is like all the places you can go to and it's like usually there's like a pool
you go into and I call it the gate and then there's this place called the train tracks because
there's this train tracks and then there was the mall and it was like there's a banded mall
whoop I just smacked my microphone and then there was like weirdly like my grandparents house
my other grandparents house my mom's there and there's like a bunch of other places and there
were there were always constant in my dreams um so I would go from place to place and I would
find other places to add to like the hub very weird I don't know why my dreams do that like this
the dream that I woke up from today um because I hadn't lucid dreamed in a very long time uh
it was like I remember being outside my body and just or I'm usually I'm usually I've already said
this before in dreams too I'm usually not myself in my dreams I usually have like a bird's eye
perspective it's usually like I'm watching a movie or like watching something take place
but this time I was myself and I was outside my body seeing myself talk to like a group of people
and I was talking to them and I'm like hey I'm sorry I haven't been back in a long time I haven't
woken up in a while and I was just and then I woke up and I was like what the fuck it was just
fucking weird no not that hub you fuckers um yeah it's just my dreams are very vivid and weird um
I made it that they start yet bro we ended like two hours ago I'm so sorry my the stream was at
the stream was at six eastern time so we've heard you're three hours late I'm just talking about
stuff now um I'm crying don't cry I wish I could lose the dream
why do you have to ask your trips to blend to your sandy yeah so the context of this
chapter that I'd written it was like a spin-off of like my dream lucid dream world because I've
had this since I was like a little kid like a very little kid it's always been there's also this
place called like the factory there's another play like it's really weird why my I don't know why
my mind does that I'm like I don't have any fucking trauma that my mind would do that um maybe I'm
just like the Lulu when I'm sleeping I don't know she'd be inception but literally though
like I like that movie a lot because it's very it's very similar
my dreams are absolutely mental and extremely specific and detailed at times yes like I have
I literally have a I have a journal next to me where I used to write down my dreams pretty often
because again a lot of my dreams I feel like would make really good books
um because like I never elaborated on the crocodile dream that I had the other day I just
said you saved me from a crocodile there was so much more than that uh we were like you know
like old like trope and like writing that was like like maximum ride like the gifted on the run
like we were like that it was like me and harem on the run because we all had superpowers and like
there was one person that was chasing us that I think he turned into a crocodile and then we
killed him and ate him I have I have batched fucking dreams um I remember talking to my one of
my therapists one time and I'm like is there something wrong with me and she's like well you
know your dreams are just you know your mind working out stuff when when you're asleep from
what happened during the day and I'm like I don't think my mind does that because I never
dream about the real world I like yeah how are we actually cool yeah you guys were cool
I felt like I was in like a reverse harem atome game there's like a bunch of hot harem members
around me and we're all like on the run with our superpowers I can't remember it's been too long
for me to remember what the superpowers were but I think a lot of them are elemental
I explain why I drew a vtuber right are we cool no you're not
it's none of you cool you're only cool in my dreams I suppose
I might have not been me if it was a hot member
you have the drip no we were we were all like wearing the same outfit we were all in like
jumpsuits like it was fucking like um uh I almost said bakugan what the fuck is it anime
uh my hero academia
it's a good game it almost kind of likes your game too um
yeah and I remember we were like and then at one point we had to escape a jail
um but it was really cool to like watch it because we were all like like my dreams are also
the favorite character has arrived free and I go eat
my cat's food is going off
and then the other one will go off in like four minutes um
but um yeah my it's like I'll never have like my cats and my dreams or my parents and my dreams
it's very it's never I usually never dream about myself
very odd hi Toma it's dinner time for the harem go get your food here to your dispensers going off
it's Spencer my favorite streamer I know Strani and um I think somebody else that I was streaming with
oh yeah I think it was like Poseidon and Apollo they were just like wow I love the addition of the
cat food this thing I was like a really good character I was on the umibus I can't remember
oh everybody's been very happy with your muppetizing um of Azura by the way
you know how all faces and dreams are ones you see walking around day to day life
I've heard that I have very yeah I see like and you know how like you're not supposed to be able to
read in dreams I can read in dreams I don't I can read stuff it doesn't like get jumbled
I can control stuff it's weird because like
there's like there's a consistent pattern of like me being a god of like this fucking like a just a
really toxic goddess of my dream realm so when people don't like react a certain way I like smite them
you're a muppet fan art for me what is there a muppet was cute it's like big bird big bird here
yeah I feel like yeah I was yeah I was really old testament
chibi I'm not even joking
he doesn't want it what do you mean she doesn't want it did she say she just want to be muppetized
this is not like a dream to me yeah I was very
I'm a very harsh god forced to reckon with in greek inter-egyptian mythology and it's it's
interesting too because it's like again my dreams don't end they usually continue or
consistent or it's like I'm the god looking at like another portion of my world or I'm like oh this
weird shit's happening over here like I remember having like a
a like horror related dream of like these people had like mutated this like monster thing and it
escaped and it was literally like alien and I was just watching it take place but I wasn't scared
because I'm like oh I'm not a part of this I'm just a god oh my god that bitch just died oh yeah
she got yoinked she was dragged down a hallway by some like weird
tentacles that sucks for her oh she just exploded across the wall anyways um back to go do my godly
duties oh immy immy immy
scary world not all my world is scary in my mind I guess hi immy I miss immy so much
no you're not I'm not finishing I've literally just been chatting for like an hour about my
weird ass dreams and my weird ass fan fiction well not fan fiction but let's like create a writing
stuff I wrote when I was younger um I hope you had a good like how was your comeback stream
tell me the deeds I'll have a look at the bond I was like really bummed that you were streaming
at the same time as you I was like I want to watch oh
I'm so happy to be back I know I know your pen pals miss you so much and even like I know some
of my hair and members who also watch you miss you and where can I read no he's not fanfics I'm
digging through my old emails I sent to my um creative writing teacher then I found like some
weird oh the other cat who the thing is going off um and I found like a uh a little sister
you did us here hi hi um and then I found like an old story I wrote about like my weird dreams
yeah having a great stream I hope you guys had a good stream
hello hi if you don't watch me although you probably know who I am I don't know why I'm
going to bother introducing myself I'm your favorite girl failure dom
um and I can gap for hours um I should pull up my go xlr and just start and just start uh
serenading all of you in fact let me do that get serenaded I'm going to sing
in me a welcome home song hold on a moment I still have like left for dead open
I never turned it off
oh my gosh
okay welcome home freestyle I need to put in my headphones so I can hear what the heck I'm
going to be saying what's a song what would what's a song you would like that I hopefully know in me
I think I'll call last 30 minutes or a dawn stream and it was chill as fuck yeah I'm usually a
chill as fuck person I tell how it is I just hang out you know I just hang out and chat
give them advice I'm sweet I'm mean I'm anything you want me to be baby girl I can't think of one
let me think my hard ninja was not holding out for a hero
just goes live in chills I really do though I just fucking
holding out for a hero I see
see
this is a really good song
now I want to I need to listen to the background music
I'm just gonna look up a karaoke video but I'm gonna keep it muted so this doesn't get
claimed
a little bit of body Tyler
give me back to my suggestion up
off off I'm not gonna it's not gonna be good oh god holy there we go oh sorry
put the reverb on get the echo
okay where is it this ad is still going
I didn't have ad black or blacker blocker on this song on chrome yes I'm using chrome you
know if you can hate on me I like whatever I can't believe for anything okay
why is this so quiet
this is so I can't even hear it
I'm so sorry I'm already choking
I have to impress the girl I have to I just I have to be good I have to
oh it's playing for my other headphones I'm so stupid
you guys could probably hear it because I have my headphones hanging on my mic arm
yeah
maybe I should listen to the actual song because I can't remember what it sounds like
I should just sing the strapped version
yeah
oh
Amy we missed you so much baby girl this is for you
they're gone
Why am I high pitched?
No!
Was that?
Whatever.
It's a cute and funny cover.
I don't know what I'm going to receive.
By the toss and I turn and I dream of what I need.
I need an Emmy.
The Emmy goes to her Emmy till the end of the night.
And she's gone.
She's gone.
I need an Emmy.
I need an Emmy till the end of the night.
And she's got to be strong, and she's got to be fast, and she's got to be fast, and she's got to be strong.
And she's got to be strong, and she's got to be fast, and she's got to be fast.
I need an Emmy till the end of the night.
She's cute and small.
Oh my God, I'm watching a lyric video, this isn't working out for me.
I can't do this.
I can't put it off my feet.
I need an Emmy.
Wait.
I'm holding out for an Emmy till the end of the night.
She's got to be stronger.
She's got to be faster.
She's got to be fresh from the fight.
From her flight.
Because she went on a trip.
I'm holding out for an Emmy till the end of the night.
It's my real voice.
I don't know.
I'm not even messing with the pitch.
It's like doing it by itself.
Okay.
Let's start that.
I don't know why hard tune is automatically making me high pitch.
Oh my god.
I wish you guys could hear the background music.
Honey, she is cute.
But you guys know I can do a cute and funny voice without the need of that.
That's not a squeaky twig.
I need a hero.
I need a hero till the end of the night.
Raina, stop chewing on my headphones.
Stop it.
And she's got to be strong.
And she's got to be...
It's cheering on my headphones.
Raina, please.
I'm begging you.
Stop.
Why are you purring?
Let's go.
She's just me out.
She's like, hey.
Okay, this pitch sounds more normal.
Yeah, because this one I'm just voice acting.
Wow.
I need a hero.
Are you continuing to sing into the thick of it?
Oh yeah, earlier.
Into the thick of it.
Me.
I'm marching through the woods.
On and on we push.
And we don't know where we're going.
Into the thick of it.
Oh, isn't that like a crap version of something?
Great.
I'm just going to start singing for the rest of the stream again because this is fun.
No instrumentals.
I'll probably do a karaoke stream when I come back though.
I'm definitely going to do that.
Only bangers today.
I will sing you an actual song.
I can't believe you called me Chibi.
I'm really hurt.
In the arms of an angel.
This was Chibi Chibi Boys.
Ooh.
People forgot that I was cute and funny before.
Me out here waiting for that BBL Chibi cover.
What would it be that?
My anaconda don't.
My anaconda don't want none unless you got buns, hun.
Boy toy named Troy used to live in Detroit.
I don't know the rest of the song.
Addiction to love Florence and the Machine.
That's hard.
I don't know if Florence and the Machine are kidding me.
The perfect song to talk to you.
I think I've done the whole, like,
sort of mix a lot rap before.
I thought you were going to go into doodle-bob with them.
Oh, I'm annoyed.
I'm annoyed.
You're booming.
What's that?
What's that one song?
Don't cry.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
And now I want to sing you a song.
And I'm going to sing you My Immortal.
I'm so tired of being here.
I'm depressed by all my childish fears.
And if you have to leave, I wish that you'd just leave.
I can't sing, by the way.
Because your presence still lingers here.
And it won't leave me alone.
These wounds won't seem to heal.
This plane is just too real.
There's just too much that time cannot be erased.
When you cry, I wipe away all of your tears.
When you scream, I bite away all of your fears.
And I held your hand through all these years.
Where you still have all of me.
That time could not erase.
For Cease to sing beautifully?
No, I don't think so.
I wanted to get, like, actual singing lessons.
My hand is a G.
That's another...
I'm going to do just Evanescence songs now.
Is Bring Me to Life by Evanescence Emo?
People also ask.
Well, sometimes I can hear it, like, peek with my breath.
Because it's trying to, like, filter them out.
How can...
Well, hold on.
Take a drink of water.
Wake me up! Wake me up inside!
Can't wake up! Can't wake up!
Save me! Save me from the nothing in the door!
I love that cover, by the way.
Um...
How can you see into my eyes, like open doors?
Leading you down into my core.
Where I've become so numb.
If I was, like, classically trained,
I know I could be a really good singer, but I'm not.
I also have the tendency...
I usually sing, like, the person who is singing
because of my ekolaleat.
So, like, yeah.
Wake me up! Wake me up inside!
Yeah, I can't...
I'm also not good with music in general.
Like, I don't have perfect pitch or anything, so...
This song hits so hard.
When my dad is sad, he blasts Evanescence.
Don't tell him I told you that.
Just imagine coach in his car, he's blasting Evanescence.
You're already a good singer?
No, no, I need to, I need to, like, practice and train.
But thank you, Amy.
He's valid for that.
It's the reverb, the reverb's helping me if I take it off.
Am I arms?
Forget it.
Falsetto, you stick to rapping.
It's like, I don't even know what my range is.
It's like, I can sing pretty deeply
because I'm more comfortable singing a lower note
Like, I can sing, like, male song songs a little bit easier
because I naturally have a deeper voice.
But because I have a...
Why? The voice strings, I can go really high.
Or really low. I can, like, kind of adapt when needed.
But yeah, I've been practicing a lot.
So they really want to make sure that I do Stacey's mom some justice.
My head voice is deeper than most people's chest voice.
It makes it hard to sing.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I know that does have a factor.
Stacey, can I come over?
After school, oh, oh, oh
After, wait.
After school
We can hang around
by the pu-pu-pu-poo
Oh, oh, oh, oh
Hang by the pool
Did your mom get back
from her business trip?
Business trip
Is she there?
Or is she trying to give me the slip?
Give me the slip
You know I'm not the little girl
that I used to be
And since your dad walked out
your mom could use a girl like me
Stacey's mom
because I can't go that high
I can't belt
Stacey's mom has got it
That's why in my doing your mom cover
it sounds like I'm like quiet
Has got it going on
She's all that I wanted
I've waited for so long
Stacey, can't you see
you're just not the girl for me
I know it might be wrong
but I'm in love with Stacey's mom
na na na na na na na na na na
na na na na na na
I love video kill the radio star
ooh-wuh-ooh-wuh
boom-boom-boom-boom-boom
boom-boom-boom-boom-boom-boom
ah-tah-muh ah-ah
Biddy, I'll kill the radio star. Biddy, I'll kill the radio star.
In my mind and in my heart, something, something you've gone too far.
Oh, uh, uh, uh, oh.
Going for soup. Oh, yeah.
I already made a joke of when I think, when I was first playing with the Go XLR, someone said 1985 and I was doing, what did I say?
She be just hit the wall, she never had it all.
One prozac a day, harem's kinda gay.
Her dreams went out the door when she turned 54.
Only then would no man, what happened to her plan?
She was gonna be an actress, she was gonna be a star.
She was gonna shake her ass on the hood of Yaku's car and her yellow SUV is now the enemy.
All right, since Cinder, Nukstaku, waiting on Face Connect, there was Pixelink and Bishoujo, music still on YouTube music.
I want to do parodies. I already have one parody in mind, but I'm not gonna tell you what it is.
Because I have to, it's gonna take a lot to do it.
Because I want to make a whole animated music video for it.
I got your picture coming with you, dear Maria, count me in.
There's a story at the bottom of this bottle and I'm the pen.
I had you in the first one.
Just eat it.
You guys can see I'm also moving a lot.
I need a 3D model so bad because you guys can't see how much I'm gesturing and dancing while I'm doing this.
Honestly, like, stuck in the drive-thru is one of my favorite, like, jokie songs.
Just eat it.
How often do you get the mic?
Sorry, we can tell.
I know, I'm like, I'm swinging my hand.
I'm like, I'm smacking my, what's the thing that suspends it?
Oh, I need to fix the wires on it, though.
There we go.
Sometimes the wires slip.
I don't remember whether to start something.
I need a burp.
No burps for you.
They get muted.
Check, yes, Juliet, are you with me?
Rain is pouring down on the sidewalk.
Sorry.
Denied.
Mambo number five.
A little bit of straw knee in my life.
A little bit, a little bit of mercy.
It works because a lot of our names end in E, so that actually would work.
A little bit of Zura in the sun.
A little bit of Emmy all night long.
A little bit of shivvy makes me your man, your woman, your woman, your Dom.
Yeah, but then he does say Jessica, so you can say Azura because it's the same syllables.
A little bit of icy going on.
The snowberries are like, don't forget icy.
Don't worry, I didn't forget icy.
What's that one rap?
Every time I see Icy's name, I think of that one rap by Saweetie.
No, I don't want the Wikipedia page.
Can't stop. Won't stop.
Gikwap.
Ten white toes in them.
Tori.
Flip flops.
Many cures of pedicures.
I'm always tip top.
I'm not hot.
All these lies need to stop because I'm icy.
Wifey.
Haters want to fight me.
Never been the one to get a wrap up on a white tee.
Keep my hands clean.
Got some hitters moving shiesty.
Asking if I'm rolling with some Gucci bitch I might be.
It's very unlikely.
My wrist looking icy.
Charge it by the minute because my time is very pricey.
Ain't no rest for the wicked.
Money don't grow on trees.
I like to, I am very good.
I think I'm good at rapping.
I used to do karaoke a little.
I think I did like a whole like Childish Gambino karaoke and Tyler, Tyler the creator karaoke
because they're my favorite rappers.
I think I did, I think I did like a Kendrick one.
But I was rapping bonfire and everybody was like losing their minds.
It was so funny.
You're very good.
Thanks.
All right.
It's Childish Gambino.
Homegirls drop it like the NASDAQ move white girls like there's coke up my ass crack.
I just fucking love Childish Gambino's lyricism.
Junior mom is an exemplary pretty good.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Honestly, I will sing praises of mercy, however, because she did her whole song in one take
because she thought she had to.
She never recorded things before.
Never recorded music.
Neither have I, but I didn't think that she's just like one shot.
She did that all in one fucking take.
Can you believe that?
My, my, my gen mates are so talented.
Yeah, I love Mercy's cover.
Like she's like, I don't like it.
I'm like, this is freaking flames.
Why don't you call 45 karaoke bar?
Well, I think what was the last?
When I first started at my job, my last job, which was almost six years ago for like a
team building thing that took the new hires out to karaoke.
And that was the first time I hung out with Olive and we sing.
What are we saying together?
We sang the Spice Girls.
If you want to be my lover, that was really cute.
I'll tell you what I want.
I want to really, really want.
So tell me what you want.
What you really, really want.
I want to, I want to, I want to, I want to, I want to really, really, really sing.
If you want to be my lover, you got to get with my friends.
They can last forever.
Friendship never ends.
If you want to be my lover.
You guys can't see, but I'm really rocking.
Yeah, it was really great.
That literally was the beginning of our friendship to sing that together with her.
Can't wait for me to be on their covers.
Yes, I'm working on one.
Do I need to work on one?
Maybe I'll do that.
When I come back, I don't want to over, overdo myself because I'm already going to work on
probably a gameplay video and then an ASMR video.
I don't really rock the Spice Girls.
I'll dance however I want.
I'm just waving my arms around and then I just end up really rocking.
Ooh, a cover.
Yeah.
I want to, my next cover is going to be Stacey's mom.
100%.
Slay queen.
And then Shawnee says I have to cover five bars, five seconds.
So I will do that next.
Because that'll be a funny short, actually.
Actually, I think since I already technically did that in my Elden Drink stream or my Haiti stream,
I can't remember which one it was.
That should be clipped.
Wait, I think someone did clip it.
And I'm just going to package it down even more and then make it into a short in the scent
of Shawnee because it'll make her day.
Play all those arms queen.
It's funny.
I'm still learning how to pilot my model properly because I move my arms a lot,
but I don't move my body.
But I'm like, no, you got to move around.
You got to bounce with it.
You wouldn't rock with it.
Oh, I forgot to put my cover up on.
Oh, frick.
Shit.
No.
Sorry.
What do you mean?
No, I knew the entire time I had reverb and echo still on.
I can't hear it in my headphones.
That's all in song.
It's great though.
You know, it's a classic echo.
Echo, echo, echo.
I love a song too.
I love that song.
Thanks for hearing from Kingdom Hearts.
Oh, it's great.
I would just like have that song repeat and also simply and clean.
I have like an essence stuck in my head so I can't bring off lyrics.
Simple and clean.
When you walk away.
Wait, no.
Take a deep breath for that one.
I know.
Sanctuary, in my opinion, is the best Kingdom Hearts song.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say, please, oh baby, don't go simple and clean.
I can hear myself peeking in my headphones.
I don't like it.
It's the way that you're breaking me feel tonight.
It's hard to let it go.
Yeah, something like that.
Also, I really used to like Tommy Heavenly.
Because I love Soul Eater as some of you may know.
I'm not.
Wait, where's the Romanji?
Oh wait, Amelie covered that?
I have to listen to that then.
Because it popped up when I was typing Romanji.
This is not Romanized.
This is the same thing as before.
My cats have the zoomies.
Yes, Black Paper Moon.
I'm late.
Hi Nori.
I'm just singing stuff.
I'm fall.
I can't hit notes, bro.
I'm falling down into my shadow.
I can also can't read Japanese.
What's my cat doing?
Raina, what are you doing?
I'm not late.
We're so up.
I can't read Japanese.
I can't read Romanji.
Don't cry.
Stop singing.
Stop crying.
I listen to a lot of Tommy Heavenly when I was younger in my weeb era and K-pop.
What's that?
Lucifer by SHINee.
This is my favorite K-pop song.
Lyrics.
Romanize.
I'm going to butcher some Korean.
Wait, the ad popped up.
I can't read this.
Raina, what are you doing?
You're like, I can hear you crashing stuff.
Just lay down, lady.
Rest in peace.
By the way.
Wait.
I also used to know the dance.
I used to know a lot of Korean choreography, K-pop choreography.
Like rocking from team top.
Team top.
We don't make team top.
We don't rock it, pop it, stop it.
I'm going to show you the choreography for that for a quick second.
She beat love by beats for cats to wreck the house too.
She knocked over like...
All my plants doing fine actually.
She didn't knock it over.
I think she just bumped it.
Heading to bed.
Have a good sleep.
Sleep.
Sleep and Eep.
Um...
I just think of Mickey Mouse.
What's up?
Oh, something here.
What are you doing?
She just has her head buried in the crook of my elbow.
Eating the Korean produce right now.
I'm going to show you real...
No, you can look it up.
Look up team top rocking.
The song used to go so hard.
I used to be able to know the choreography team top.
And to scroll in like the middle.
Fucking ad bro.
Yes, you'll see the Mickey.
Sleep is slipping out.
Such a bop.
Yeah, I really like K-pop because of the urban influences in it.
And it was like a combination of like Asian culture and urban culture.
And I like literally just like start shuffling in this music video and it was so sick.
So I had to learn it.
And I preferred male choreography because they actually dance.
The girls just like walked around all cutely.
Actually, no, that's a lie.
I did like electric shock from girls generation.
It's a girls generation.
No, it was by FX.
E-E-E-E electric shock.
Na na na na na na.
E-E-E electric shock.
That was a nice gauge for girls generation.
Listening to new jeans around the home.
He's got some questioning or friendship.
New jeans is good.
I don't really listen to a lot of Korean music anymore, though.
I usually just listen to, I've been listening to a lot of Tyler.
A lot of K-Tranota.
I've been going through my old music and listening to it since I was listening to my self-indulgence the other day.
I have a very wide taste of music.
Very wide range, wide taste of music.
And people talk about things they like will not have any clue what they're talking about as long as they're on my first date.
Boomi, what are you doing?
Boomi, are you Zoomin?
Are you Metro Zoomin? Metro Boomin Zoomin?
Why are you running everywhere?
I'm just like jumping.
Please don't chew on my wires. Thank you. Thank you very much. I appreciate it. Woo!
Why are you running? Why are you running?
I have electric shock stuck in my head.
Sorry, I got distracted by reading fanfiction, my own old class stuff, and then singing.
I am so sorry.
I just get so distracted in the sidetracks.
You never knew cats got Zoomies? Are you kidding me? Cats are Zoomie masters.
You thought dogs were its cats, dude.
Are you gonna leave?
I don't know.
Why am I streaming tomorrow? Hold on.
I think I'm streaming. Why does my mic sound like it's cutting out?
It's like really weird sounding because it's trying to filter my voice for whatever fucking reason.
It's really kind of annoying. I wish I would stop doing that.
And some of my singing was nice. Keywords, some, some.
What does that do? I'm just pressing buttons on my goXLR wondering what the heck's going on.
I mean, I'm like, why is the gate so high?
That's why it's, I don't know why. Sometimes it like messes up stuff on purpose.
That's my cat, Tokyo drifting if you didn't hear.
I couldn't tell you which one it was though because they're all just standing and staring at each other like that one.
Because it had fun.
Can he drive? No, he can't.
If you know how they live in Tokyo, if you've seen it and you need it and you know you have to go fast and furious.
Drift, drift, drift, fast and furious.
Drift, drift, drift.
That song goes so hard. I want to watch Fast and Furious Tokyo Drift now.
I haven't watched that in a long time.
That's pretty clever.
That was pretty clever.
I listened to that song so much you triggered something in my brain.
Fast and Furious is never the same after that.
I haven't seen, I think the last movie I saw was like either Fast 5 or Fast 6.
I heard that they're on the 11th movie now or it's in production.
Thank you by the way, Morgan for the tip.
The last one was like 4.
Tokyo Drift was like not even a good one though.
The text to speech didn't go off because I have my desktop audio muted.
So don't worry.
Because I didn't, when I was playing music earlier from when I was singing to Emmy, I didn't want to mess it up.
And like it claimed or something.
I get demonetized either way because of my tickle bitties.
Oh, my neighbors don't hate me too much.
I'm singing at the same level as my TV when I put it up.
It's fine.
Tokyo Drift was the third one.
Honestly, the first, second, and third were good.
Tokyo Drift wasn't good but soundtrack and scene were good.
I agree with that.
Hardcore.
I put my BGM back up so we're not just like listening to weird silence in my AC lightly in the background.
Wait, why weren't they allowed to film in Shibuya?
I didn't know that.
I honestly just wish the main character wasn't that dude.
I wish it was Paul Walker.
He just like randomly is in Japan for no reason.
I feel like that would have been funny.
It's like, uh, Brian, we heard about, what was his name?
Wasn't it Ryan?
We heard about something.
Oh, Brian, that's what it was.
Brian, we heard about something and we need you to go to Japan because you know about this stuff.
Go.
Oh, people are, oh, that's terrible actually.
It wasn't safe.
Oh my God.
Damn.
Oh, let me, let's look at my schedule because I said I was going to do that.
Okay, so, yeah, we have Elden Ring tomorrow and then Elden Ring after that.
Because we're getting to the DLC.
I've been reading up on the DLC by the way.
I don't care about spoilers and shit.
I like to go into games like this prepared.
And so I was watching like things you should do and like what levels you should be at and all that stuff.
So the next two days are playing Elden Ring.
And honestly, I don't think we already be redone.
I still have to go and kill Godfree, which is going to take fucking forever.
Do I have to kill his mirage self or do I have to actually kill him?
Because in my game, I didn't even bother fighting him.
I just killed his fake version and that was it.
I never fought Horaloo.
Yeah, I need to get Moog.
Okay, okay, the mirage.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
That's fine then.
I have to kill Moog.
And for that, I was looking up what Moog's week two and it's literally blood poison.
Like anything that like procs after a long time like scarlet rot.
I'm like, but the thing is he's like,
he has resistance like 40% to like fire or like 80% to like fucking fire or something.
And then like 40% to all the others or 20% to all the others to all the other elements.
I think he's like 20 or 40 or 30% resistant to magic.
So I'm wondering if I need to get another fucking weapon.
Probably worth killing the last two sacred tears.
That's a good point.
I killed, I remember in my first playthrough, I killed Morgoth on the first try and I was really
or like the, at least like the third try and I was like, what?
That's because I was just spamming the black knife the entire time to get that like death blight.
Yeah, I'm just wondering if it's going to be smart going into the Moog fight with the moon veil.
I don't think so.
Um.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then we have on Saturday, which I'm really, really looking forward to is the rating VTubers designs.
I can't wait.
It's going to be fun.
And then we have the May plus concert watch along on Sunday.
And then before I leave on Thursday,
a little sneak peek of my schedule ahead.
We're doing the Twilight watch along on Monday the 15th.
And unless I might change that because I have to bring Reina to the doctor that day too at 9am.
So if everything's fine, then yes, it will continue.
If it's not fine, I will keep you posted.
And then I have a collab with Mercy on Tuesday.
I convinced her to play Super Bunny Man with me.
And I know we're going to have lots of fun and laugh at that.
And then Wednesday before I go, I'm going to do an ASMR stream where I'm your big sister and I put makeup on you as torture.
And then yeah, and then I'll be gone until I so technically I'm back.
The 22nd or 23rd.
I can't remember.
I have to look at my flight.
Can't remember if it's early or late.
And then I might take like the 23rd just like off just so I can like get my bearings,
but I might do a gorilla that day if I feel good enough.
But yeah, I just want to keep you guys posted because you know, I like to keep you guys posted.
Yeah, I'm going to doll you up.
I'm going to like torture you and be like, I need to practice makeup makeup skills for like prom.
So sit down and you guys can't move.
And then I'm just going to like be doing a bunch of shit to you.
Yeah, you're my baby doll.
I'm going to start calling you baby doll.
Hey, baby doll.
Hello, honey.
Hello, my baby doll.
I can't wait to play with you and break you.
Hey, God, I hear your phones.
I mean, this little sister she views big sis.
Exactly.
I am your, um, Oni.
Oni?
I forget the honor effect pronunciation.
You guys know your Bible is acting up.
You should probably smack it down.
My hot woman.
You can't keep doing this to me.
I'm going to die.
Oni, son.
Well darn too.
And I'll be your Oni-san.
Emo-shi-mo-shi.
I just think of that one tick.
That girl who speaks like fluent Japanese when she does it all on a southern accent as a joke.
Arigata gozaimasu.
Itadakimasu.
Sue.
Shibine-chan.
It sounded like Callie.
I've gotten that before.
If you don't come back speaking...
I don't know what that means.
Go-mana-sorry.
That's one of my favorite like off-handed things.
Yeah, I'm pretty accurate when I mimic you guys.
Go-mana-sorry.
Sorry.
Am I Canadian?
Off the bed.
Thanks for watching your evening with my comedy and entertainment personality.
Thank you.
Have a good one.
Thanks for stopping by.
I always like, I think, I think I genuinely like seeing people from the other girls,
um, whatchamacallits, uh, fanbases.
And because I'm just like, I'm glad that you can also enjoy me too.
Like I might not be your Oshi, but you're like, you're still like,
when your Oshi's not on, you can just be like,
you know what, I'm gonna hang out with my bro today.
Okay, yeah, so that just continues.
It never ends.
Got home from work.
She's still straight.
You guys know I never stop.
Japanese and singing classes for madam.
She be my bro-shi.
I love bro-shi.
That's actually awesome.
I'll be your bro-shi.
That's funny.
I like how the thing that I was initially doing,
which is reading up my like personal writings when I was a teenager,
I just never looked to find the one I want,
because I wanted to show you the actual like wolf one that I have written
about my Oshi Cassander.
He was a beautiful white wolf.
And he was killed by his own brother like Mufasa Scar style.
Kami bro-shi.
I was Cassander with a C.
I would often get a lot of my names inspired by Greek mythology,
or just Greek.
Or even like William Shakespeare characters.
Yeah, he got Mufasa.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
I wonder if I just look up Cassander.
No, that's not it.
Nope, nope, nope.
And maybe it wasn't, I didn't save it.
That's a bummer.
I thought it would have been underdraft.
No.
Arner, clary, not the water.
Search the archive.
RIP.
Writing stream to make up for it?
No, I'm not the same.
Like actually, I was an okay writer when I was younger.
I don't, I haven't written in such a long time.
Like actively.
Oh man, I must be lost on one of my old computers.
Oh my god, Reyna.
Relax, lady.
You need to, oh my god.
She just like threw herself on my desk.
My god, woman.
Creative writing memory stream.
I mean, I'm sorry that she knows you're leaving, I know.
I just don't want her to hurt herself because sometimes she just throws herself on my desk
and then she trips over my go XLR and my keyboard and I'm like, no, lady.
Yeah, Strani was telling me that you guys liked the script writing stream.
I'm a little self-conscious about my writing, which is why I haven't written any of my own scripts yet.
Ellie showed you what I wrote when I was much younger because I have the excuse to say I was much younger
because it's that cringy.
She lives with her cast, not the other way around.
What?
These rice cakes taste like TV static and I started barfing up 50 colds.
I know, yeah, I was wondering if I should write my own script.
I just don't like, I'm not, I don't, I write, I don't write scripts.
Like I could probably write a story.
Like I can write like amazing smut for you if you want of me and Harum or me and insert your name,
like a fanfiction of us together.
I can do that very easily.
But like writing, I've never, did I write it?
Did I write a script in theater class?
I did like one theater class when I was younger.
I can't remember if I wrote a script though.
Might have.
Haven't all jacked it out for you.
Yeah.
But it's like, but then I like, again, I've read like we have a script writer and then like
Shrani's are in scripts and I've seen in fact, I have to record a script for Emmy for a special
little treat that she wants to record together.
But and like, I'm like, I think I could, it might not be as good, but it would just be like,
at least a starting point.
And then you guys could like, obviously like give me a critique and examples.
So yeah, maybe when I come back, I want to do, in fact, I want to make my schedule right now for when I come back.
Because I want to do Hades.
Let's do Wednesday.
We'll do because I usually do member Mondays.
So we'll do Wednesday.
I'll do the members stream.
I'll do script writing.
Remember stream.
I want to play.
I put the wrong time.
Or p.m.
I also have to make time to hang out with Tomo.
Then I have a collab with DEMPA coming up.
I have so much shit to do guys.
I'm so busy.
And then I still want it when I come back.
I want to record my next two months of audios for Patreon.
So I'm going to be a busy fucking bee, but I like it though.
It keeps me busy because otherwise I just lay around and that's not fun.
Let's see.
I take Sundays off so I can work on other stuff.
So I'm not going to do anything on Sunday.
What day did I say with Tomo that I would hang out?
Let me look at my camera.
I just looked at Discord for the first time in a while and I'm laughing because Imi sent a meme.
I said, I must be Sonic the way I'm hedging my hog.
I fucking love her so much.
Why is she so funny for no reason?
Tomo are you still here about looking at the chat?
No, I think she disappeared.
I don't know if she's streaming or anything.
I don't know.
Okay, I might have to be the week after that I do want the Tomo because I don't.
I don't think we actually sell alone a day.
Okay, I'll do Hades on Thursday.
Hades.
Wait, no, I want to do the member stream.
Discard.
No, I want to do karaoke really bad for real.
Should I do it?
I'll ask you guys.
If you and only if you're a member answer this question, would you prefer it be an archive?
Because like what sucks about an unarchived karaoke member stream is that not all members might be able to see it.
So I'm debating if that's a good idea.
Because I don't want could always do a rebroadcast.
Anyway, Patreon members could see no.
There's Patreon content and there's YouTube content.
They are two separate entities, but I appreciate if you support me on one.
And if you can't support me on the other, that is fine.
But also a girl got to eat.
I just can't hit.
Like there's also there has to be a reason why you want to become a member, you know, and it's for the fun, cool stuff, member stuff.
Re-broadcasting, I don't know what that means.
Oh, I'm getting cramps and it hurts.
You just rebroadcast of the stream, but like stream you stream the unarchived pod.
Oh, oh, okay.
No, yeah, that's actually a good idea.
That's what Narissa does.
Okay, then I'm going to copy Narissa.
That's smart because then I can just stream and record.
I need to get a new SSD because I'm running out of space.
I have like maybe 300 gigabytes left and I have like so many fucking because no, you know what I need to fucking do?
I need an uninstall overwatch and fucking call of duty.
That's what I needed to uninstall and save up like 600 gigabytes from that alone.
The 1080, you mean my 1070?
I like I'll probably I'll probably get a new PC when I do a donathon.
Like I'll probably make the proceeds go to that.
Actually, I don't really know because like my PC is fine.
It's not like dying.
I just have to uninstall stuff because I'm like, I know a portion of donathon proceeds.
I'm definitely going to put towards like paying off FIA and Reyna's medical bills and then the rest I'll probably maybe like 3D model because I really want a 3D model really bad.
It's funny.
I used to like hate 3D models and then I just realized how much I want one to single like people what people do with 3D models.
So work expense.
Yeah, I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
A 40 series to be cheaper.
That's a good point.
If you upgrade the 1070 or 100%, I know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I'm trying to think what my power supply is.
What the fuck?
Again, I built this like so long ago.
I'll have to build a whole new fucking PC and I'm not looking forward to it.
I'll be honest with you.
I might just buy a pre-build because I just I don't have the patience to try to put a PC together again.
I used to love doing it because I did it very often.
I would my dad and I used to work for him.
He would just give me PCs to build and unbuild and fix and update and stuff.
But I just don't feel like doing that.
I think I have a 700 watt power supply.
I think I have a maybe kind of find that my email.
Let me see if I...
I think I have a 700 watt gold something power supply.
7050 at zero.
Okay.
So then I probably, yeah, I don't think I don't have a 750.
I thought I had a 1000 watt, but I don't.
How...
What the fuck?
I look up PC part picker to see if I like took a screenshot of something and I'm getting all these emails of all this role plays that I did.
That doesn't make any sense how these are coming up.
What the fuck?
Oops.
Sorry.
Sorry, I mislike distracted reading stuff that I wrote when I was younger.
I'm sorry.
I just told her like disassociating.
Cause I was like, oh, interesting.
interesting so it was like some fanfic about the cuz I remember I told you I
don't know if you guys recall I um did are you like made OCs for like soul eater
so it was like a soul eater fanfic so I was like oh fascinating
I can't find shit I'm so pissed right now I can't even think straight cuz
these cramps are fucking hurting me so fucking bad it just hit me all of a
sudden yeah the solid it's like I know I might just like sit with myself when
I'm like when I'm like bored at my grandparents just my iPad and just be
like fascinating let's read your shit I remember you said you made the dudes bang
each other a lot I definitely did I couldn't find anything of that though
although there was like a saved file that's a schmutz stuff but I didn't
look at it oh yeah I love soul eater um pre-built is fine make sure the parts oh
yeah no like the thing is it's so much better to not buy pre-built because when
you build it yourself you can really get the parts at better prices because they
usually just overinflate their fucking part like the computer prices so I'm
probably gonna end up cuz like I remember management told me how much
Azura's computer was I was like there's no way you needed to spend that much
money on her computer cuz I could have built her a way better computer for a
fraction of the price um but PC building stream that'd be funny I think I I did do
that before I did it back when I was a flush streamer I did a PC building
stream on like um I forget it's not ready to be fun I don't think I would ever do
that just because of copyright issues you have to understand that I'm very
limited in what I can do without getting caught by YouTube just to be realistic
um I think I might have to get off cuz I'm in a lot of pain right now I love
building PCs I want to build one of them already I used to definitely have that
like fervorant passion for building PCs but now I'm just like I see it as more of
a chore because then I gotta make sure everything's good I'm also traumatized
because the last time I had to build my PC it was because I couldn't remember if
it was Rena or Sole through open my case fan and shorted out my motherboard in
my graphics card so I had to rebuild it and buy a lot of new parts and I was
crying and bawling my eyes out for days because it was so much money because I
had spent I'd saved the money I'd sold stuff and I remember it was so fucked
because my mom told me I think I couldn't remember if she told me it was
Rena and it was Sole if it was Sole and she told me it was Rena and she had
apparently known one of them had thrown up in my fan and heard it but didn't
stop me when I turned on the computer because I could have probably like
cleaned them off with like alcohol and like wiped it and like made sure
everything was good she never told me so I turned on my computer and it fucking
shorted it are you gonna be rich or free of your past self yeah I was like when I
was working like a really shitty job actually no it wasn't a shitty job at
all I was a fine job I was definitely underpaid but you know what can you
expect when you're like 15 yeah but I was yeah I was they threw up in the case
fan because the case fan was on top because Rena would like and Sole would
like to they like to lay on my fucking PC because they liked the heat that came
off of it now on my desk they can't do that because there's a rack there where
I usually put my some of my peripherals like at my controller and stuff and some
other peripheral stuff like wires and like all like my gloves for like
handcams and stuff and so they can't do that because then like I also had so much
cat hair and Mike like I had a constantly blow air through it when Rena and Sole
would sit on it because they just a cat hair was just accumulating crazy and
that's why I ended up getting a case that cuz like my case initially wasn't
that clear you couldn't see like the inner and the inner parts of it so like
every once in a while I have to open up my computer to see if it was okay and
then I would just see a shit on a cat hair and I was like oh yeah but yeah I'm
like I'm still don't know what plans will be for the donothon again that's far
ahead but it feels like it's approaching fast to a more months until my
birthday it's quite nerve-wracking I usually celebrate my birthday alone
usually don't celebrate it at all to be honest with you so it'll be nice to spend
it with you guys let's have a fun time cuz yeah HD app is great if you are fuel
yeah no I know I know my limits I'll get off when I want to
spoil you on that day what do you want for your b-day I just want you guys to
show up that's it I don't care I don't care about anything else if you guys come
on my birthday to be fine that's all I want I just want you guys to hang out
with me like it just sucks like I've been alone I was alone on my birthday last
time and it was so fucking hard so yeah a birthday September 28th I'm a Libra
that matters not this area it's bunny day
being alone on a birthday even worse is not it's like my family doesn't celebrate
birthdays for religious reasons so it's like I'm used to it but since I left and
I would celebrate my birthday with friends and now I miss like not I just like
don't leave my house that much anymore I'm not gonna be lying to you I'm very
much like a neat at this point since I quit my job which I don't mind cuz I
like I'm introverted so I preferred this way but I'm I now know the pain of
being alone at a holiday before I didn't care at all can't believe you're
born on your birthday I know right but yeah I know it'll be great I really want
to plan some some cool stuff maybe like maybe a Muppet model reveal maybe some
sort of I just want I want to treat you guys cuz I want to be able to entertain
you guys so please let me know in like Maros and stuff and don't don't forget I
still read Maros I just haven't answered them publicly but I do read them and I
do appreciate them and I do love you guys immensely I got so many lovey Maros
the other day and it made me feel so good thank you for that I appreciate it
so much hi Pookie do they win we did we actually we didn't all die at all which
was very impressive to be honest with you
Rhea carried us but it was fine but please let me know what you guys would
like to see in my donut on I've done a donut on once but I only did it for a
day because Fia ended up being really sick and I couldn't continue it I'm not
really I did like I did like a wheel I think and I did like some push-ups and
some like sit-ups and some squats and stuff is like punishment but give me
ideas I know I'm gonna ask like scrawny for ideas and the other girls for ideas
but I especially I value your opinion you're gonna be the one who's watching so
please let me know yes even the incredibly down bad Maros hot sauce
challenge food definitely want me to die one time I had like the last dab
right before a work meeting and then my friend Salem specifically she was just
like hey can you lead this meeting and I'm like I'm literally dying because
someone dared me in the break room to have a bit of the last stab and you want
me to read the meeting you know what fine and people were laughing the entire
time because I was just hiccuping and like trying not to throw up in my mouth
and just like me like anyways today in the schedule we have and then I ended up
chatting creamer it was great cuz we didn't have any milk in our in our
office fridge the voices for five minutes I think I had that when I did my last
on the phone it was nice I my ear is itchy today I don't fucking why I get bit
by something am I dying just dying slowly my body's falling apart um yeah like
maybe yeah maybe maybe for the donut on you guys can hand out but are they
punishments me you don't know I quite like pain
minus when it's my period cramps oh how we hold the turn to me and I mean it's
how the turn the turn tables not how we hold the turn tables how the tables turn
how the turn tables if you laugh you lose I do have a collar I have a shock
collar I haven't used it yet I've been trying to think of something but a
period similar thing count as a bat suit episode what happens during not your
week I would just wait till I had my period to do that
what would be the point why would I simulate something I already get naturally
that was just fucking sucks yeah I have a collar I haven't used it yet I'm
wondering what it feels like I haven't played with it it's just been sitting in
the box next to my bed you want to shock me you don't get to say anything you in
particular don't forget oh by the way if you disrespect me I will remember that
for a very long time this this person right here called me a bitch on Twitter
mods jump his ass cat I cast a stick your torsion you have to apologize profusely
on your knees if you say if you call me anything attached to your name you better
hop on an alt motherfucker because I will hold that against you until I feel like
it no I don't usually hold grudges but I'm just feeling I just feeling mean
today yeah notice how he got quiet real quick you coward you cowardly son of a
bitch I need my get where's my apology come on come on group pegging you're
laughing stop laughing everybody peg his ass that doesn't that doesn't sound
legit no I want you to write a fucking paragraph right now about how sorry you
are for calling me a bitch that's because I feel like I don't really care if you
call me a bitch hell most of you guys call me the end word probably so whatever
but I need to make an example everybody correct them right now
like what wait a minute I'll post it like no post it right now I'm waiting
patiently I'm a very nice person if you do this you don't have to worry about
anything else and by the way this isn't just go for this person in particular no
no you're gonna post it in the chat I want everybody to see ma'am I have to
proofread too bad you had plenty of opportunities to apologize sooner you
didn't so I have to make an example out of you and this will happen to anybody if
you call me it just because I feel like it by the way not because I'm actually
offended but because I don't like brats and I don't like people that bite back
so you will get slapped and push down and I will stomp on your balls any wrong
doers no no no but you'll just be embarrassed in front of everybody it's
not gonna be like a nice oh sexual thing we're like yes madam seven me out no
we're all gonna make fun of your ass there's another person in the chat that
I've been tempted to call out but I won't because it was a it was like the
whole like jealousy thing that I'm like I'm over that do it humiliation is some
people's king I don't think it's this person's kink though
everybody look is like hoping it's them I feel like you guys are gonna go like
I remember it was today you guys are such brats might you guys are such fucking
brats I wish you were in front of me so I could legitimately strangle you until
you pass out what did I say today I said I made the joke of like did you unfollow
me which is a copypasta mind you people took it seriously which I thought it was
funny cuz they're like oh madam oh role plays back I'm like no it's supposed to
be cringy and you're supposed to fucking laugh at it you fucking idiots and then
some of you are like oh maybe I shouldn't follow huh is it fall you back and
I'm like okay you're so fucking annoying no I'm following don't follow me back I
don't want you if you're gonna be a brat if we're gonna try to be smart I don't
care tooks him in the shit wait that's illegal that's what it was I can't believe
you guys have never seen that copypasta before you told us to read a book on
Twitter yeah and you're behaving and you're reading it I hope
brat breaking is fun it's only fun if you're here in person I feel like it
would be better if I could like physically hurt you in person which I
can't in Minecraft of course not in real life then I'd feel better about it but I
can't you would look so lovely covered in all bruises made by me I always laugh at
my own emote with the fucking step
VR chat meetup where I beat the shit out of everybody in Minecraft in VR chat
bro still hasn't apologized our heads like I didn't forget I didn't forget I
didn't forget all right I'm I'm sorry she be for being a little brat I should
have not called you that I will listen to every word you say from now on please
forgive me I will do anything for your forgiveness all right that is
satisfactory I want you to lick another harlott's asshole I want you to role
play that right now I forget I can just make you guys do things I'm gonna have
you all just start role-playing you just making out with each other just for my
personal pleasure so go ahead all of you not just him all of you just do it I
want you to kiss the person next to you I can't do this on zips I joined at the
wrong time cunny rabbit accepts Dinkus apology for KHD all right who's next to
me all right who's next to me can know you can't excuse yourself kiss the
person to you next to you mistress tell us what happens when you struggle or
fight back again I'll make an example out of you that's what will happen I'll
have to choke you you'll have to stop when you have to beat you for your
insolence you stupid little slut and you won't grovel under my heels for days
and I will never let you up for air swear to God I'll make you wear my
underwear over your head stuff it in your mouth you will smell nothing but me
taste nothing but me live nothing but me and I will make you crawl on all fours
every hour of the day I will use you and your back as a footstool for when I'm
tired I need to put up my feet
and of course I'll lock you in the cage
not a different cage than Mercy's cage it's a skinnier cage if you didn't
notice in the in my bedroom hold on let's let's pop over there real quick
so in my bedroom there's a cage as you can see you won't it's a rack almost but
I'm not gonna allow you to stand I mean to sit you're gonna only be able to
stand for hours you'll be strapped to this and then I'll drip stuff on you
like the wax you see the stuff then you can see like my my stuff to flog you
with I have a lot of stuff in my room as you can see just multiple hours you
know this the use just the use just the usual
should make a background that has this being in the cage that'd be funny how is
this a pun no one asked you to speak shut up I'm gonna start calling out some
of you
let's see who do I feel like picking on next all the gray names in this chat
shut up you don't get to fucking speak what gives you the right to think you
can sit here in my chat say that you love me you're poor it's five fucking
dollars you imbecile I'm kidding I can't I can't be me when it comes to money
because I don't know people's situation it's cuz that's really shitty damn calling
up the four I'm sorry I've said my no my lurk no wait oh boy thank you let's hope
you get hit with it ah yeah some of you guys some of my my lurkers aren't you
lucky I have a quarter to Rubik's Cube I'll take the Rubik's Cube let's go I'm
talking privilege I'm not thanking you for that thank you Eternity for the 20
gifted oh what the heck's happening I stopped vouching for each other thank you
amphibian for the gifted why do you have your full name as your fucking username
are you stupid you're just asking to get caught what is happening right now
thank you Joker for the 10 I guess you guys are okay for giving me gifted no I
don't I don't like I don't like branching into this sort of area cuz then it
just makes me sound like I'm being a fucking fendom and I fucking hate that so
I'm just gonna stop but thank you all for the gifted YouTube like silence I'll
be nice to you you apologize you're just easy to pick on if you're easy to pick
on if you're an easy target I'm going to take advantage of that by the way I'm
dodgy he's gonna be my next target who wants to be bullied right now
any meanie miney do your worst do your worst you don't have even have my
oh she marks in your name why do you have the fucking leet speak in your
your fucking username bro hey I don't have even seen you spoke with who are
you who even are you wait a minute who are you don't get bullied
how'd I bully you with your little ooo hands go away Jesus Christ that was
pathetic you're all pathetic you're generally all so fucking pathetic I
volunteer tribute who are you I've never seen you before you just came out of
the fucking would work I volunteer should be I don't know you are you a
lurker who who I know that guy I'm just a great name I don't even deserve your
bullying madam yeah can I volunteer now this is gonna turn into me roasting your
names again cuz some of you guys have some dumb ass oh that's too bad you
didn't get you just yeah you just you got terrible luck bro
predictions are harsh in the punishment roast mine I can't even fucking read
that you have to enable oh yeah that's true you do have to enable gifted that
be funny if you didn't have it enabled this entire time your name is barbecue
because you like barbecue bro I can't be a tribute I'm too scared I like how all
my lurkers start talking when I'm just like I just start insulting people do
have to do that more often to get you guys to talk no not that I want to
force you guys to talk I love my lurkers lurkers as you as you will
but it's just funny it's lead speak because eight billion people take all
the good stuff so you you really thought you're you couldn't come up with a more
clever name that wasn't taken than whatever the fuck that is I'm not even
gonna say your name cuz it's not worth to utter it from my lips I'm in my
sleepy voice I should be doing this in my patreon voice madam's doming brings
out the best of people Jesus she be get his ass don't think don't think you're
safe either you are a little bitch who sits on the sidelines and watches your
boys get hurt and you don't stand up for them terrible you are not a real one we
are never safe I just enjoy being here okay I'm a she be let's not talk about
names here after that Elden rings out so I remember what was said about your last
name excuse me excuse me what's my Spanish level why do you need to know
I don't care me I'm all
hmm watching the boys gonna hurt popcorn in hand this guy is the name of a
video game character you know how that's that goes he watched so many he he
probably didn't play the game he just watched what the playthroughs he's
weaponizing my streams I don't my mods are forever dead so I don't think I've
seen a modern days but uh mods get his ass a vealer lover madam is
I love when you guys make names that are just like either just like really tailored
to your OSHI or the person that you watch like I think I saw like I see he's
Dada and I'm like that's cute and obviously like I haven't seen my left shoe
where did my left shoe go where's she be his left shoe I haven't they just die
they just fucking fucked off I lost my shoe they're not coming back and I
already lost my right shoe so I'll ever get my shoe back I see his cream I don't
know who that is
I'm shoeless my toes are just barking and they're out and about I know there was
a stream playing for the name of strontis removed toenail I bet they
honestly let's like change their name temporarily then change it back so my
foot's oh yeah my foot stools around on Twitter they're pretty active it was you
I don't believe you you're lying prove it I don't know how I can prove that she
is parked I should keep a track never how left shoes hi Raina see what's up
mama you want you wanna snuggle if you chew my headphones I'm I have to what
are you doing Raina don't chew my headphones you can't even lay down like
walking all over me Raina you're gonna fall and you're making me nervous you're
like standing on the arm of my chair oh my god lady just lay down let's hang out
good girl
I'll show you the prints on Maros the what the dick prints what do you mean by
prints or the proof wait until you have dedicated clippers all the barks will be
recorded I do have like I think like two people I just like there is one I was
looking through my clips to send to stronti and they're just one person who
just clips literally everything I do and I have to go through everything and I'm
like holy shit thank god though cuz I appreciate all clippers where she bees
mole I know right I want to get more moles and beauty marks on my model for
future stuff question about clips you want edited ones the ones from YouTube I
prefer like I prefer edited ones but again that's work that you're doing so if
you want to do it then that's great but if you don't if you just want to clip
like something you thought was funny I look I go through my clips and I send
them to the clippers so like if you wanted you extra work it's up to you you
don't have to you know sorry Rena's rubbing against my microphone so if you
hear some weird like snuffling noises that's her because she's standing on my
legs and she's just like like that I might have heard her for split second
Rena are you gonna purge into me we're gonna get some rain appraised
I heard her for like a split second I was like
Rena get her rubbed out okay well she's she's rubbing against the microphone
she loves to headbutt the microphone she's so funny I don't know why she does
that she's loves to sit on my lap and I'm streaming and headbutt the microphone
Rena why are you pushing off of my leg like that
cat cam me I slowly just set that up I've been I honestly I haven't been doing
it because I'm still not comfortable showing myself yet because sometimes I
do like end up in frame not like my face or anything but just like my arm or
whatever and I just want to be careful so cat cam will come a lot later now I
just scratched my fucking eyeball Rena coming in with the content sorry my
microphone's so far away from me now let me bring closer yeah it took a it's a
can you not chew on my headphones lady Jesus Christ I give you I liked it
better when you rubbing against my microphone Rena it's not a toy she's
like oh delicious she loves rubber and like the casing of my wires is rubber
and she's trying to chew on it you're so much of ish and you're such an old woman
and you just want to chew stuff Rena choose on my crocs
I'm gonna chew on my shoes she's like a fucking dog
the audacity you did that on purpose I'm not giving you I'm not giving you the
pleasure of no no go away go away you're trying to get a rise out of me it's
not working oh by the way hold on a second I needed I wanted to say this on
stream rather than say it in a tweet so when I was streaming with mercy the
other day do not on her stream or any of the girls' stream I don't care if you
do it on mine I don't give a shit don't super chat her and then say someone
else is your oh she if you were there you probably saw us all pause because we
were just like who the fuck does that but like to that person they probably
were fine with it but it's just poor etiquette and I was very irritated on
behalf of her if you do it in mine I don't care but mercy has explicitly said
before that it makes her uncomfortable when people do stuff like that and then
this person goes ahead and do it don't fucking do that also I might need to add
a rule to stop making chat about yourself because people have been doing
that lately and I'm just like um actually you're here to watch me or the
person that I'm streaming with stop making the chat about yourself you're
not a chat celebrity this is why we don't have mods that you can see because
they're gonna be try to become chat celebrities
mods peck him yeah and like I appreciate this person because they do do
Supas on my stream and they like whatever but it is if it is poor etiquette to
talk about someone who is not present and say that they are your oh she because
that was after this is when the person was gone and we were no longer
collabing with this person and it was just being mercy and we were shooting
shit that this happened and I did not like that at all I was very irritated on
behalf of mercy I'm very protective of my girls and if you hurt their feelings I
will fucking come for you I swear to God I will rip your face off and I know like
again it was innocent they probably didn't know but it's just such in such
poor tastes and I just wanted to say something about that but yeah if you if
you do Supas like to make stuff about yourself like oh this is happening to
me or like this I don't I'm sorry but do you you don't use Supa as a medium to
make a conversation about you we're all here to have fun we're all here to
escape from life we yeah I don't appreciate attention see behavior and
donations I'm sorry but I don't no yeah but you guys know what I'll call you out
yeah you guys know I'll call you out because I'm very blunt I'll probably do
a little bit more nicer than what I'm doing now but yeah but yeah you guys
know that I'm I'm nice I have my moments where I'm very nice I'll be honest with
you and I've said this to the other girls I'm very thankful for the kayfabe
that I have because I feel like I can get away with telling you guys to stop
fucking doing something stupid when I tell you to whereas if like Azura did
that people would be like probably like so off-put by it but if it's me they're
just like oh she's just being she be she's the Dom you know whereas like Azura be
like I can't believe she on me I'm such a bad son to my mommy goat goddess or
like scrawny but I you I do this because also some of the girls just don't
have the courage to say stuff like this and I will be the big sister I will say
something because I again I am very protective of my gen mates they are my
sisters when I call them my sisters they are my sisters I was birthed from
scrawny's loins or she laid an egg I don't fucking know whatever cul-de-fiche do
I put them I put them before myself I will protect their sanity and their
mental before my own because I care about them that much the Lord gets a little
weird yeah people can't correct themselves they never told what's wrong
that's why like I'll tell you guys like what I appreciate about harem what I
appreciate about you guys is that you guys are very receptive to feedback and
then again I am also I think I put it in a better way because I'm very real with
you guys I hope so angry she be as hot but scary at the same time you guys
actually haven't seen me actually mad yet if you saw me actually mad you'd
probably unsubscribe actually no no that that would not actually was never
streamed though the one time when I raged and I broke my headset I think would
have frightened some people she protects you protect but mostly importantly
she got their back exactly no you guys you guys are like you guys are very
receptive like when I like when I was getting a lot of like stuff in my
maros or this was happening or that was happening I'd be like hey guys what the
fuck's going on you guys can't do this and then they're just like oh shit okay
never mind and then it just stops and then there's like trolls and shit and
that's whatever
but also I just I say stuff and I put there are rules in place to protect
everyone as well don't forget that I want to make sure that everyone is having a
good time because after the girls then I put you there and then myself because I
am here to entertain I'm here to make you feel good I'm here to have you
heck you have a good time you come to my streams to have fun you come to my
streams for an escape and I will provide as such as I do care about you I do love
you all and I wouldn't be you know where I am without you so I say this like
every fucking stream that's because I just can't get over how thankful I am for
you guys but yeah a lot of my stuff is teasing anyways like I don't know I'm
just I'm just a very good actress you guys can't tell if I'm well I just sound
like a server second guys can't tell if I'm really mad or not I can't I didn't
know a zur has a lisp and she was like explaining it to me and I'm like that I
think that's the only reason I can't do your voice is because I can't do the
lisp because I didn't notice she had one I'm just that oblivious I suppose I am a
Sarah to lay the fertility goddess
repetition doesn't make any less meaningful so I'm glad to hear it oh
so I guess you're an Amy Wednesday if I again I want to do a stream I want to do
a collab but maybe I'll do it I think we're gonna have Amy where the fuck did
you come from she's like hi I was really good to say I want to like have like all
the girls so I can do maybe the most recent in the next group collab I'll
try to mimic all their voices and make them talk
little sister jump scare oh if you named your cat tongue eater instead
maybe it's the biggest she be fan
am a strong e strong e strong yeah cuz she says strong e she doesn't say strong
e and I'm like it's strong e she's like that's what I'm saying I'm like no
you're not your Scottish was the other day gave you a chuckle yeah if Amy's the
biggest she be fan I'm the biggest Amy fan I watch all the girls it's like it's
like what's funny for me it's like I'm also very picky about my vTubers that I
watch and I'll well if I'm not streaming I'll just watch the girl like I've I
seen the background so often when I'm doing stuff minus when she's like really
going hardcore with her dad is because then I'm like that's this isn't for me
this is for somebody else I am not the target demographic
I don't know that I don't like it but you know it's just not for me it's all
the convoluted strong e birth two girls and the reeflings are tough but she also
give birth to the reeflings it's fair it's very like America like it's very
Elden Ring Lore give you a data too if you put your cards right I am a mama
actually get it right I'm a mama she calls me mama no she doesn't I should
give that me literally that though I'm like I should give them their privacy I
love like honestly I love going into streams and watching you guys cuz I
I'll just lurk watching guys interact with the other girls I just love it so
much cuz it's so wholesome sometimes it's not but most the time it is like I
love watching just like it's and then like the different personalities of each
fan base it's just so funny like I remember watching a zero the other day
and I was just like chilling watching her like in the background she was like
playing League or whatever and then like just like how like the bleeding hearts
are so sappy it is so adorable whoa mama oh my just crack my knuckles so I'm
about to fucking crack her skull about that it's lewd summer hold some I like
that and you know pinpals are funny I the snowberries are funny the I love the
reflings as like as you guys know I was an og refling myself so I'm already
familiar with that sort of community they're always so sweet and so silly I
love I what I love about the reflings is that um it's they're like so like they
like Gosling so hard if like there's anybody that Gosling it's the reflings
like and it's like you have like like Emmy and I see and then I we and obviously
we all in mercy all have really devoted fan bases but for like but for reflings
it's like legit Gosling and then honestly the what I appreciate but
appreciate about the the snippets the senpaises are so respectful they're like
I just really appreciate you letting mercy go at your own pace if you're a
snippet excuse me the reefing is like a parasitic fish for the long time we
waited 400,000 days and hours and months but yeah I just I I'm so happy that mercy
can feel is like growing to be more comfortable with you guys it's been
3,000 years but it's just it's just nice it's nice to see how the chat reflects
the streamer yeah at the speed due because I was worried about that because
like I went false the wall I mean my false the wall I see my false the wall
and same with the zero to the very respectful and everybody goes at their
own pace me I went balls to the wall because I have a desperation and I'll
say this easily because I'm I'm open and honest with you I have a desperation to
be liked and loved so I'm like if I piss will you love me if you listen to me
pissing in my toilet will you love me I hope so I'm still a woman at the end of
the day guys like I'm on I love attention what do you expect what do you
expect I'm still a girl I'm very needy when I want to be I just hide it well
madams bit not that was great I thought she was a bro not a man dropped I'm so
sorry hold on hey how's it going did you miss me it's me Shabrowski
what do you mean you attention no way daddy oh my god you guys are so
daddy damn she won't know that was that was all I can go deep like this like hey
what's up but um that was the that was the oh my god what the hell holy shit
thank you what the hell thank you for that big-ass don't know dumps in the chat
holy shit this is for you hold on I need to
Miro you're such a good boy for that or girl I don't know really know what
anybody is so you're a good thank you appreciate it again any time you donate
it goes towards my bills and feeding my cats so and myself appreciate that
six on the table you don't have to leave again nice male voice good pet that's a
good point like cuz like I know I have girls I watch me and then some people
want to be called I do you know a girl so I realized I awoke some of you of some
you when I said I would call the good girls good girls and then some of the
guys were like wait I actually like that good sub yeah that's true the negative
person yeah the good boy and girl does hit different it is true every time we
hear cats feeder go off you should dedicate that feeding to a donator it's
funny I used to in my PL used to donate not donate I used to dedicate each
burp to somebody so if somebody did like a the channel redeem cuz I used to
stream on Twitch I'd be like oh insert name here that burp was for you and then
they would redeem so then they would get the next burp called out for them but
you guys don't deserve my birds my burps anymore so sorry oh my god
you put my mic closer cuz like I love how my model is like leaning off to the
side awkwardly madam is too powerful for us yeah and that's your punishment
because I feel like oh are you crying you little wussy baby do I need to shove
my tit in your mouth so you shut the fuck up I do spoil you guys I'm like that's
just Domazura what I just said haha what the fuck is that laugh Jesus Christ
someone did a clip of me laughing three different ways in a minute and I watched
it I was like what the fuck is wrong with me it was when I was playing Hades and I
got the the hit seven enemies cuz that consecutively when I throw it and I was
like and I was just like going absolutely crazy do you like spoiling us
debatable my laughs are infectious I'm a manly man with hair everywhere being
called a good girl gets my feet kicking in the air we are at the whim of
a vengeful goddess may these are asked to be forgiven she starts associating
from sick I really do though I just get really excited have you tried Hades
who too I just started playing Hades the first one I love it I still didn't
finish my schedule that I was writing I'm gonna wait to do that I'm gonna wait
until tomorrow to do that what's the day what day is it okay I don't have
anything that can tell me the day what day is it guys can you guys tell me what
day it's Wednesday it's Wednesday I thought it was Tuesday bro what the fuck
I don't know where I am who am I where am I what's happening it's Wednesday my
dude so there's a in some places you're not wrong tomorrow's payday oh shit why
are you saying she be she be don't give me that yeah we got Elden ring the next
two days I literally looked at my schedule earlier never got there it is
we have Elden ring tomorrow so what I'm thinking is I have to get the mimic
tier so I'm wondering if I go to no cron or whatever the fuck the underwater
plate the sofra sofra sofra I don't pronounce it it's Irish see oh fra not
no cron not okay I think it's a sofra so sure you guys know what I mean wherever
the wherever the mimic tier is good night have a good one thank you for the
gifted again see you tomorrow for the Elden Ring Stream it will be Thursday in
an hour for me I should like make an original song for my BGM
don't oh well what I was saying earlier cuz someone brought it up they said I
wasn't what was it cuz I was talking about be meaning intention I've already
said I'm a very lovey affectionate person sometimes it slips out sometimes it
doesn't sometimes I play it being mean and just grunt old you know it's a really
bossy dom good night even very interesting name
the song is you persona five vibes she based everything off of all strongy I
mean when I say she strongy our lord and savior strongy our lordess and savior
our lady and savior strongy if you will she based all of our BGMs off of what
sonic heroes or sonic a sonic game sonic games which is so yeah the sonic
yes tease I am a cruel madam with a heart of gold that's very accurate but
what I was gonna say I used to be very under a very needy I still am I just I
just put that part deep down inside of me so you guys can't tell sometimes she
comes out every once in a while I just can't help it but there's many sides to
this she beat coin cube callback to a Rubik's Cube I'm just rambling now cuz
I'm tired my hair is so fluffy
loving and Dom yeah I still want the Rubik's Cube but she be cool in today
you're amazing no you no wait not you okay it's always funny when I have to
record an audio and it says like I get like a directors note for me to giggle
and you guys probably notice that I giggle very shortly I'm like because I
don't I don't giggle cutely I can't be like hey like I can't do that so I'm
just like like that's all I can do when I giggle otherwise I was like to either
watch the Vaude now or watch the boys wait is the boys out of the boys is out
on Thursdays is it our Wednesdays I know I did that on purpose I think it's kind
of cute my laugh is I just think of like that one clip with like Justin Bieber and
that one like lady I think they're on like Ellen DeGeneres and she was like
laughing like and he's like I like your laugh I'm like made fun of her Fran oh
yeah I can't think of anything to say from that show from the nanny drops at
midnight Thursday one so it'll drop in like an hour I don't think I'll be able
to stay up to watch it Janice from friends type laugh literally oh my god
fucking Janice I totally forgot about that
Sonic adventures or something what are you guys even talking I like sometimes
I'll glance and I'll look at to see like what little miniature conversation you
guys are having and I'm just completely lost now I just started watching season
one yesterday after watching catching up some eldering streams oh nice nice nice
what do you think what do you guys think of the boys I have someone in my
maros lately that keeps asking me about the boys like you know that one I like
tweeted one thing they're like do you have a cave like like tech night and I'm
like yeah but then like I keep getting more and more questions about like the
boys episode like my opinions on the boys and I think that's so adorable I
think your laugh is pretty nice I'd laugh like five different ways so pick
your poison sometimes I'll be like sometimes I'm like sometimes I'll be
like like I'm just I'm very versatile with my laughter and right out the
season see what happens alright I've seen the boys but a lot of my co-workers
but you've seen it so you might watch it what I think you might just say it might
not watch it when I show I'm looking forward to a severance I like binge
watched it during the period where we hadn't debuted yet cuz I was like I
finished all my work really fast cuz I'm just like that and I am a people
pleaser and I'm like mom be proud of me here's all the work I've done I done
three month stuff in advance and all the shorts and all the stuff that you ask me
to here you go and so I just like was bored and so I had nothing to do for
like a couple weeks I just started binge watching shows I binge watch euphoria
the TV show live action with Zendaya not what you're thinking of and I binge
watch severance and those are really good you watch the boys until season 3
season 3
sorry it's yawning how did you know I was thinking about that cuz everybody
every time they said like oh I like the euphoria TV show with Zendaya
everybody's like why the novel the book I never even fucking played that or
read it or whatever the fuck I just know it's bad
the yonies let's just start yawning cutely I'm just gonna start yawning like
in burping and doing and sneezing everything like an anime character so
you guys love me no burps are not back fuck off I know the yeah I've heard the
visual that was a trip I don't think you can burp cutely oh and me burps pretty
cutely actually no she burps like harder than I do
slowly to the beat of this just
gonna pick your ass I'm gonna pick your ass I'm gonna pick now velar talent has
meet the demon summoning Belchi that was so funny that was I need to like find
that Korean soda again cuz that was insane during that wolf quest stream
somebody clipped it I sent it to Stroni so she gives in to our our editors oh
that's so funny
hi booby
it was so funny he was so grumpy the next day after I am streamed till 4am he
like was such a brat because I'm like I think he was tired cuz he was up his
boomy boomy's not like a super snugly cat but he always follows me around and
like is has to be in the same room as me for some reason and so I think like I
think like he was like really grumpy and overtired like a little baby my little
boomy boy yeah he fell asleep that's me yeah he was like he never crawls into my
arms like that usually he'll just like sleep in the bed that I have on my desk
and he usually only like only likes headpats a little and like when his head
is rubbed otherwise he doesn't he'll just like hang out near you but he won't
like snuggle on top of you like Fia or Reino will or like sit on your lap cats
they're cool I love cats I can't stop yawning contemplating staying up again
for that no I'm not gonna stay up that long because my sleep schedule has been
shit the only reason why I'm up so late right now is because I slept for like
three hours I think I yeah I fell asleep at like 12 and I woke up at 3 and I was
like oh shit and I fell asleep again I'm set an alarm and I woke up at 5 or like
a little bit before yeah like 445 to check on the girls if they're ready for
the collab speaking which I should have like ended this stream and like started
a new one because the collab is gonna be like two hours and then three hours is
me just literally fucking talking what's wrong with me am I the yappiest
yapper in all the West need sleep schedules different I don't want to be
a need no I'm literally sitting here in a big t-shirt my hair is a fluffy puffy
mess my glasses are crooked I'm half asleep I'm not wearing pants I'm just
wearing a big t-shirt my toes are out I'm wrapped up in a blanket I am neat
maxing but I showered yesterday oh hi boomie oh yeah see boomies coming to
tell me it's time for bed I think I'm just gonna take that as it is now when
he comes up and starts being lovey he's like please go to sleep mother give you
a little forehead kiss are you going you're walking all over my keyboard
please don't chew on my headphones like Raina what is wrong with both of you
here I'll hold you well see plop to my arms quite nicely usually you don't
like being held actually no boomie's actually very good at being held
what a distinguished young man look at this man look at how he was sitting so
distinguished getting his chin scratchy's okay I'm gonna put you on the
floor now you're so heavy it's ridiculous you have to be like 15 pounds
bro boomie is a good son he's like mother please Raina does too Raina will
literally if I watch I can get up right now and you guys will hear Raina yell at
me sorry that's booming playing with a toy if you guys didn't hear that let me
see if let's see if it works when he's playing with a toy and Raina's staring at
me
you guys want treats you want treats yeah yeah where'd she just come from he's like
plop off one with a bed
did you guys hear it let me see oh you did
Raina knows that she always gets treats before bed
where did the treats go
where did I put them
oh
oh what's this you want those cat name treats ooh did that the harem got you
how nice of that harem they got you treats
they are munching they are munching away
yeah what I love about Siamese treats is that they're very vocal so like Raina
always talks back to me boomie doesn't talk he just like hums he like sounds a
little dove and I call my little trumpet so be like and then Fio sometimes just
only really meows to herself it's kind of funny she'll be like playing with a toy
and then she'll start yelling starts like caramel dancing
EP knows but I love that full man
can you guys not hiss at each other damn you guys ate those so fucking fast did
you chew oh Raina is angry because I think they ate the treats that she was
eating hold on I don't know if you're gonna hear fucking hissing cuz she's
like she's sniffed Fia and then you're so mad you're looking for trees okay I'm
pretty sure
you do a little spin can you jump Raina can you sit sit sit good girl my cats no
tricks they also fetch leave her alone these are hers leave it yeah
don't eat so fast you're gonna fucking vomit she's like gagged because she was
like inhaling her treats they like really like those it's the catnip ones
Raina usually likes the tuna ones but she really likes the catnip one we don't
want to try something new although I can't look at chat I haven't been able to look at
making sure that the cats give her her space so she can have her treats
All right, I'm always going you know I'm always here
Fetch yeah, I'm pretty sure
Boomi and Fia just like vacuumed those up because I put out so many and I only saw reina like chewing one
Yeah, yeah reina knows oh my god, boomi what the fuck why are you throwing your toy at me?
reina knows sit
The other cats do fetch reina does fetch too
Just didn't she be as funny for some reason
Hmm
He wants more treats
Yeah, well Fia is circling me
She is sniffing my socks because I took my socks off and I forgot them there and
I'll see you like sweet so that's very young character for her to start sniffing my socks
Hmm
One of us
What the heck is happening to my chat? Let me fix this
Bro, how do I get ads on my own videos? This is so funny me
I like have you guys another window
Grippers out my grippers are out
Slipping the line
Me if I was a cat she'd be as a divorce argument in the next room is
That'd be funny
And be popping up writing. I usually sometimes I'll set them to like balanced, but
Yeah, it's a little bit. I wish I could set them to like pre-rolls only
Because then you guys it would just get eaten by like the way that's what I like to do at twitch
Is because I can usually have the pre-rolls roll set and then I would just have them get like
You wouldn't miss anything because it would just be eaten by the um the waiting the starting soon screen
Getting that ad revenue for yourself girl boss activity again, I don't have a job. This is my job now
Streaming is my job
But I wouldn't have it any other way. I love it here
Um
I have to go to bed. Thanks for the fun stream. Have fun. Oh my cats have the zoomies now
I don't know if you guys heard him. He like made a funny noise
Raina stand up for yourself. No, no, she does plenty. She's rain is the alpha cat in the house
So they're probably just playing
I
Well, I'm the alpha cat but then like rain is in charge, you know, she's my second
Command they're in their rebellious phase. Yeah
She's fucking his statham because he just was some boomy is uh
Boomy and fia just turned a year old because they're they're still little babies. They're still kittens in my eyes and raina's 14
So they they verse they uh
definitely
Tests their matriarch very often
but um
Raina really has warmed up to fia and I think cuz fia reminds her a lot of her sister soley
They have very similar personalities. So she'll often snuggle with fia. It's very cute
Um, but yeah, raina put some in their place
They're just it's so funny how like similar cats and dogs are a lot more similar than you think with like their hierarchal system
um
Yeah, they are little babies my little babies
I wanted raina to have a friend
Um, it's actually none of those spellings. It's rain with an a
um
I wanted raina to have a friend because I was um
Going back to work after working from home for six months. So I didn't want her to be alone
In a new apartment by herself. And so I got boomy
I never had a boy or like a male cat before because I was just like, oh, let me try getting a male cat
I shouldn't have done that. I should have just stayed with the female cat
Um, not that I wish I did to get boomy. I love boomy. He's my little son my little boy. Um,
But she fucking hated him
Hated him so much. I was I was like, I don't know if it was like and I did all the proper things
Like I made sure they're in separate rooms. They're in separate rooms for a long time
I would like move towels around so they could smell each other like how you properly introduce a cat
And she fucking hated him and she still does. Um, it's funny because boomy has the biggest crush on raina
100% he's just like give me some of that koo grass
because it'll like he'll
Koo at her to play like he'll like get real low and be like
Oh
And then raina would just like be like this is like walk away
Like he tries to like he doesn't do that to fia. He doesn't do that
He only does that to raina and it's so funny to me. Hi boomy speak of the devil. Hi. Here's your boy
What are you doing? You just sitting and watching me? Can I get a headbutt?
Oh
Um
He wants a woman who hates him for real. Yeah, um
But then like he and I always was worried
Uh because boomy is like so much bigger than raina and I'm like, oh crap
Is boomy gonna become like the dominant cat? But no, he's not
Raina still puts him in his place and boomy is such a pussy. Like he's scared
He's such a he's such a dick, but then he just gets like you will
Accidentally move too fast and he will sprint
Into my laundry room and hide behind my laundry machine and I'm just like bro
It's I literally accidentally knocked the remote off the couch onto the carpet. It wasn't a loud noise
It was like a like a little
Fump noise and he'll just freak out
Boomy is literally awesome
Um, that'll be some alter women and he just I don't know if you heard the noise he just made um
and then fias uh then since I realized that
It wasn't I was a little bit greedy in getting a kitten for raina because I thought it would be easier for her to like
Dominate which it still that was true, but I thought they would take to each other a lot better
um
But they didn't and I I think it's is because that boomy is male
Um, although he's not like intact or anything. He's fixed. But then I so I got fia
so like
Boomy would have a playmate
as a kitten that can match his energy
and um
Then rena would have like a female companion and then it's everything's perfect like
Yeah, rena loves snuggling with fia fia was so I was I made the joke so when rena was sick
I was like fia you better not live up to your name because fia comes from fia the deathbed companion
From elden ring because I love elden ring so much
and yeah, no expected kid unexpected kids. No, thank you and um
But in but fia was like
So close like she was
With rena constantly like she was snuggling her
She was making sure she was good. She was grooming her
And I was worried because I'm like, oh is this mean like it might be the end for rena. She's older
Like I had already mentally prepared for that
but no
Reina fucking bounce back into zoom in and whatever and they just they're like really close together if they're really cute. Um
Yes, they're playing elden ring tomorrow. Yeah speaking of um
And then yeah, I always call boomy and fia the twins. They're not actually related. Um
They came from different litters. I they're both rescues from
Mississippi from the south
I went to the same um rescuer who was this really nice lady and um
One of the uh
Fia's was the sweetest girl. She's like, I've never met a more snuggly cat in my life
Oh, she's pregnant at grandpa company. Um
Yeah
How do I spell Mississippi mi ssi ssi ppi
I gotta sing it
But it's funny because they look
They look very similar
mi ssi ssi ppi. How is that wrong?
Are you from Mississippi? Never mind. Um
No, right. Thank you actually. Um
Um
They look a lot alike because I I really like
I love Siamese cats. I've always grown up with Siamese cats. I've had um
Three other Siamese cats before them
because I had um
Mari, Naomi and Salah
And um sadly
A lot like because of I like I don't think I'll ever go to a breeder again
um
Because and then my well, I didn't go it was my mom, but like I don't think I would ever get a cat from a breeder again
um just because like the health issues that even purebred cats can have um because uh
Salah died at 11
Naomi died when she was three which really sucked because she had cancer
and then
Mari died, I think at five or whatever. I can't really
know
Oh my god, did you hear that? That's boomy if you heard that he's running around
um
But yeah, so I got rescues this time because I wanted to give like some cats a chance. I was debating whether or not to
Get a what was that? I was boomy
um
I was debating whether or not to get an older cat because like what my dream would be because a lot of people neglect older animals
and I would love to get like a home and like a little cool like cat area
or like dog area where I can like um
Kind of like adopt dogs
that are older
um or cats that are older and kind of just like
Take care of them until their last days because everybody deserves that
You know, you don't deserve to be sitting in a shelter for that and just give them all the love and care and affection that they
deserve because everybody deserves that
um
and uh
Yeah, it would be really cool to do that
So I was debating whether to get an older cat but for rena's comfort ability. I got a kitten because I know she could handle a kitten
um
but yeah
fia is
Really cool because I've never seen a cat like a lynx point like her before she's technically a lilac point simis
Which is like very light purpley
color
But she has the lynx markings because I'm assuming that her dad or her mom was a tabby cat
and um
But or might have been like also a type of gray point cat because that's
cat genetics aren't weird
So she her skin is almost like purple rather than pink and she's very like lavender colored like her gray is like lavender
and which funny is that
fiala and I think check check of sabaki in her check
um means
means lavender so it also worked out that way so I can explain that to people
instead of fia the deathbed companion of fia from like a normie a person asks
Unless you're breeding for livestock or some kind of specific work rescues the more economical and morally superior choice
Yeah, the only reason why my mom got purebred simis is because she wanted
simis cats are the only cat that my mom wasn't really allergic to
Um, and so if she she thought if we got like some sort of mix
It would make her sick
And then she ends up still being like solea was fine, but rena for some reason
Um rena's dander is like bad
Like I'm mildly allergic to rena, but I'll still shove my face into her anyways because I love her to death
um
You know have a good one
Uh, but yeah, sorry. I'm like talking about my cats
I'm sorry. I'm yapping
About my cats
I can talk about my cats for like what else do I have to talk about? I'm just a fucking old lady hanging out with three cats. I'm sorry
You can continue
Why do you apologize because I'm I'm just an apologetic person. I'm just used to apologizing for a lot of shit. Okay. It's trauma. Okay. It's trauma enough
Um, I will continue to apologize for the raps. It'll never stop
You did
I thought about a pure bird myself. I'm wondering so perhaps with a cat something to the problem
Yeah, I've also like I wanted to get a pure bed dog for like protection and get them specially trained for that
Um, like a working dog
That's rena rena, what are you doing?
Oh
Reina
Hey, boomie, what are you doing to her? She's trying to sing the song of her people and you're fucking up her song
Are you okay, rena? Did you guys hear that?
My cats are
Yeah
They're fighting
Yeah, that that was rena running around from boomie because sometimes they fight over um
Our boomie just doesn't know where to stop. Let me check
Reina, are you good? She's fine
boomie
What are you doing? You know you did something bad. You were hiding from me
What are you doing? Don't give me that look
Why are you chasing her like that?
Hey, would you give a reason to do these? You have plenty of toys on the ground that you can play with or you can play with fia
Must be as hiding from you because you're being a menace
Who means like avoiding eye contact with me? He's just like
Why are you sure? Why are you doing that?
If you're spraying
Whether the game you're spraying the play with we have to find you another one
What?
Are you grumpy because you want to go into the fridge?
All right, I did catch an answer
What are you doing? I want to get you a little more low tide. You look very dapper in a low tide
You know labor alone. She doesn't want to play right now
Oh
Yeah, I warned you you get back
Let's go home you guys
Raina are you okay?
Okay
Okay, Raina in my arms
You might hear a growl because she's irritated
And when she sees if even if i'm holding her and but boomie or fear all around and she's in a bad mood she'll like
Irritatedly meow at them
Hi
We shall
Are you grumpy because boomie's chasing you
I will protect you from all around
I will be here don't
Cry it's funny because now she's purring
Fia, can you not grab my wire? It's literally like I have three kids
Except one's the oldest and then I have two twins that are just like fucking
cracked out
Oh
No, fia, don't try to bap her fucking tail. Fia's like right under my desk trying to
Try to paw at raina's tail. I know she was just trying to see raina likes to hop into my my um
bathtub
And just yell
I think she likes the acoustics in the bathtub. Oh, you want a hug? I'll give you a hug, Raina
When a purr
You want to head but the mic oh there they go
Boomie
Oh
Boomie, let's leave fia alone. Jesus. What is on what is wrong with you today? Okay, hold on
You might hear fia like yell in a moment. Yeah, that was Raina though. Hold on a second
Boomie, you're done. You're done. Come here
Come here, mister
Get up
Come on
No, don't try to cutely lick my foot. Come here
Come here get up. Why are you so fat? You're not fat. You're just heavy
Can you get up?
You're literally you know where I'm bringing you because when sometimes when boomie gets too much I have to put them in the crate
So
My ear boomie like meow in a moment
But he's he's being too much
I
Want attention to go to bed. I've given them attention all day today before I streamed
The juicy cat drama
They're catnip if they're catnip, do you think that they'd be chill?
Yeah
Sometimes like what's funny about boomie is he hates it when the cats like play independently without him
He like has to be a part of it
Like fia was just playing with like a ball and that's when boomie came over and just started like
Abiding her and I'm like dude
Booby apology video coming soon. We start riding like silent
These kittens are bouncing around jumping up walls keeping up with the cotton bums. That's actually really cute
Uh, except make the c into a k so I can be like a Kardashian or some shit
Yeah, sometimes boomie um forgets that he's so much bigger than the other girls. I've actually like
Debated getting another boy cat just for him just for a little like buddy
But I don't think I can sneak four cats in my apartment. So I'm just gonna
Speaking of that I have to reapply for my housing for my apartment and I don't know really how to do it
because
Since I don't have a job right now
Sorry I heard meowing that again fia only meows when she plays with a toy so but she sounds like she's like hurt but she's not
He's like meow meow meow and I'm like, are you okay?
So she's fine
She just gets really that's her excited meow
Boomie is cute. Yeah, he is a cutie
Yeah, hold on
Are you gonna chill?
I have a little crate for them
It's almost like a dog crate
But you can create a cat I used to create fia once you couldn't
She was sick to look that when we wouldn't try to play with her
She was very good
It's really weird telling you time these cats are very similar to mom
You
Have to sit she be
Yeah, no, they just sent me a notice to renew that's why I'm like, oh I have to fill that out
Sorry if you hear craziness in the background
um
So yeah, I have filled out a little bit of it today. I have to reach out to my former boss and be like hi
Can you let them know that I'm not there?
Can you prove to them that I'm no longer employed?
Because yeah, again
It's just
Bro, it's so stupid. Why can't I just like live?
I can't wait to buy my own house in like a couple years or something. That'd be so so so nice
Oh my dreams won't come true
Oh
I don't know what goes okay. Yeah, me too. They gave me a hard time last time
So I'm hoping that they don't give me a hard time this time
Buy a house with a basement for the hair to be lost
I
Buy a basement with a house
Okay, I wanted to see if I can stream till midnight but because my cats are being very rowdy and they're distracting me a lot
I'm just gonna I'm gonna say bye for now
But thank you for spending time with me. I appreciate it always for you guys chilling with me
Nocturnal kiddies, yeah
Obviously the parents
Sorry, I'm still yapping. I could yapp for longer but my cats are rowdy
They're like mad that I'm still like I think they also have just like a shit
Um sleep schedule because my sleep schedule is shit. So they're like chat cat reflects streamer right now
Not chat cat reflects streamer. Um, let me find someone to raid. I don't think anybody's
Oh Maro's streaming he's playing Dave the diver
Oh
I'm gonna send you guys to Maro
Why is it telling me to verify my identity? Oh fuck
I don't know what any of this shit is I'm just gonna let management deal with that. What the hell
I don't know what that means
That's why I don't stop me because I don't can't read
Okay
Bye everybody
Sorry like nine. Yeah, I've been streaming since six by the way
I've streamed for almost six hours again. I I didn't know I was an endurance streamer, but
I just can't get enough of you
Some people thought I was streaming like I like eight or something
No, I've been streaming for a while
um
I was literally gonna get off after
That stream ended
Well, then Azura said she was gonna talk to her stream. I'm like, oh, yeah, I'll talk to my stream
And then look where I am now
Three hours later
Three hours later just you know
Oh god, no
No, I can't hear it. I was like accidentally my stream is gonna play back
We love the app. Yeah, you better love the app
Well, one time I literally streamed for like almost like 11 hours and I lapped for like seven and I like remember looking back at that
Stream I'm like, what is wrong with me? I'm so lonely
Yeah
This can't shut up. I don't know
I'm so used to like being quiet and like
Being a listener, so it's kind of nice just to just to talk at people
Um
I'm giving you guys a virtual hug
Thank you
I am a lonely needy parasocial bitch
You guys get a little hug and I'm smothered here. I'm gonna put you right between my movies
like that
You guys are smothered right between my titties
I just really just talk the mic between them
Cool
I don't uh, my boobs aren't that stretchy to do that with a 3DO. I'm sorry the 3DO is a bit longer
Whereas this is like a simple at 2020
That's a little bit
Ow just set my nipple
More pillow
Yeah, 3DO is be hard. I know like I think starting to like a thigh thing, which I was like, hey, that's pretty smart
Very nice inverse of my experiment experience. Oh, how is she we stream? Oh, it's great
She ended it by smacking us with her boob
And tucking us between them and giving us a hug
I like how I haven't left yet
A part of me wants this I'm gonna stay till midnight you have eight minutes left with me
What can I talk about for eight minutes
I'm not gone yet. Come back
Come here
Get over here. Get over here. I'm wrapped up in my blinky
I'm spoiling you with my presence
Why would what would I do why would I talk about my my booba? What am I gonna say about it? They're there
They're large and in charge
I'm gonna smack myself in the face with them
Did I eat yet? Um, I had applesauce and a bite of a
I remember what it was like a case of dia. I just my tummy has been really upset. I can't eat
I don't know what's happening
Can I help you right now? I just hopped up my desk like hello
You coming to snuggle ma'am
Did you just hear a squeak she's went meh
You coming to snuggle
Why are you meowing at me?
Yes, I also have water I've been staying hydrated because I know if I can't eat I need to drink more water
You nesting now on me you just like went to a little loaf pose
Why the drills for your hair? I don't know ask strawney
You guys don't I don't know if you guys recall. I didn't the models were already made by the time I was hired
In the names. I didn't pick anything. I'm just here. I'm just a voice
strawney was like, you know what?
Your voice. I'm sorry to smack my mic because I'm waggling my finger. Your voice is the one that I want
There's a one that I want a lot a lot a lot a lot
If it was up to me, I'd be cute and funny and I'd be brown
I'd be a nice tan
cute and funny
character
I do like my drill hair I like it a lot
I
Like a brown cat. Yeah, like a brown cat
Not go I can't imagine you was a little
Do they know does he know?
That's what I was before
Before I was hired on
Yeah, boomie exactly
What are you doing? Why are you attacking the carpet?
What is the what did the carpet do to you dude?
He's like a dog I swear to god
Yeah, I was I was very cute funny
I
Talked about about it before
Sorry, you guys can hear scuffling. That's boomy
He's chewing on the carpet
What is wrong with you there's nothing under there
Boomy there's nothing under the carpet that you need. It's probably like a piece of fucking litter
Oh
My god, he's ridiculous
um
Crazy cat
Transfer students shows up and even pink was on gonga homanga bonga gongas
Um, let me hear the voices he smells it's fear
It's like it's here. I love will follow
Yeah, I can't wait. Um
I'm already thinking about ideas for the 2.0
um
Yeah, boomy knows what's up
Lead hours boomy starts tweaking
He's literally always tweaking
That's that's how he meows though. He doesn't like meow meow. He just makes that noise
It's really funny
Sometimes he'll actually meow and it honestly
Shocks me now. So I'm just like, what did you what did you just open your mouth and do an actual meow instead of just like hum?
I think what's the matter? Why'd you just hop this is boomy nearby?
The hair I'm at 3 am is pretty much boomy incarnate
Bro is doing sideways some results on the he was you don't understand. So I don't think
So what boomy was doing? He was laying on his side
and he was pulling himself
Across my hardwood floor because I have a little carpet under my chair
So doesn't make noise when it rolls around and so he's pulling himself across a carpet
On his side with his head and it's just like and then he was kicking it with his back feet
He's dragging himself along with his claws and I'm just like, okay
Um, are you good or do I like I just gave him a toy to play with he doesn't care
um
Another thing before before of course fucking boomy derail stuff
I don't remember
Oh, but yeah, so like um
Yeah, just
I don't think
I would like I would like to be cute playing again because I like speaking in my higher voice
But the thing is I don't think I could do patreon audio in my higher voice
So it would definitely be like a big gap my way moment
Maybe I could I don't know I haven't really tried because I can maintain the voice for a long time like emmy does
Um
Callous this
I was gonna make a joke whenever man
um
Higher voice works with this model. Yeah, it does like you guys
It's funny when you don't see when you see my like not my boob chest, but like my upper chest up
Like a higher voice works really well. Hi everyone. Hi, my name is she be cotton bum
um
And then when you see just my head and you don't see the like the pointiness of my chin. I look very cute and funny
Yeah, the british voice audio like really a lot of people liked it
That's funny because I can do that higher pitch british
Voice without the need of the voice changer too. I don't know why the voice changer makes it for people
Because I can go up that high
British
Hi again, it's me british she be um, I don't know if you missed me or anything, but
I know I missed you. Um, it's been
Really difficult not being able to see you these last few days. Uh
I hope you don't mind that um, I missed you so much
I just can't help that. I love you immensely
Don't don't take it the wrong way though. I just
British conny she be
British she be could be the way to yeah, we just become velour uh eu
I
Thank you forever
Yeah, it's really funny you and people a lot of people didn't think it was me as she be
Um from my pl because they're like their voices are different and then
I'm like it's voice acting
But like I do sound like my pl
Like it it comes out sometimes when I'm very excited
Oh my god, we're gonna fucking beat this guy. I swear to fucking god. I swear to god. I'm gonna kick his ass
Especially when I'm playing like like I'll just goes up
um
Yeah
So it kept up the fit
Voice acting isn't real
What are you saying?
Yeah, all these voices are mine. They're just they're all separate people just leaning into the microphone
Wait, is mercy streaming today? I don't think she is
Vilaire, but if us lost the revolutionary war
Um
Because voice changers exist
Oh, I guess that's true
Hmm guys, I don't go on vacation until the 18th. It's like I still have a week
I watched arena a little bit before Vilaire could hardly tell too. Oh, thank you. That's a compliment
Shebethany's inseparate it is shebethany comes to like just like I let her into my apartment and then she comes and she speaks to the mic
I'm already missing man. I'm right here
Oh, I'm gonna be gone until the 23rd
The 23rd
Yes, I've told chat before I'm going to see my grandparents
In florida florida
Why are you looking at me like that, rena?
Hey
Why are you so snuggly today? You've been stuck to me like, ooh, you know, I'm leaving soon, huh?
But you get to see grandma
We're technically our mom because my mom always say that me and rena and sale were sisters and she was just raising three daughters
So I guess rena's my sister
Florida man, I know it's gonna be fucking sweltering. I'm not looking forward to it
Yeah, no, I might I might I'm debating whether or not do you know bible study or not
Just because I won't be able to bible study
I had a cat sister too. I know I'm like I don't like the south for that reason
My bible I think no bible study would be fun enough for doing it together. Yeah
We should suffer
I know I'm nervous. That's why I'm nervous like I don't want my stuff to get delayed
I'm very anxious because I have a layover as well
That's another reason because I'm uh, yeah, I said this earlier, but I'm flying by myself
Because like I haven't gone to see my grandparents by myself in a very long time since I was like 16
They've been up here, but like they're older. They can't really travel that well. My parents are busy
They also my parents just left without me
recently to go see them
And I'm pissed about that so I'm going it's now my turn to go down and see them
I was secretly hoping my parents would pay for me, but they did not
They're like, sorry
They're on your own and I'm like
Yeah, I'll be I'll be getting good food
I see you
Haitian food
um
Yeah, spend time with family
It's always nice. I sometimes you need that and I think I need to disconnect a little bit
Because I'm literally on the computer like every day
Like I don't mind it, but I like I know in general. It's not healthy
And I'm like, oh, maybe I'll fix my um sleep schedule. I'm there
So quality flavor in the cell, yeah, I'm gonna get some like barbecue or something
They eaten Florida gators. I've never had gator. I don't even know if my grandparents have eaten gator
The long time that they've lived down there
I
Think he is gonna help out preventing I don't know. Yeah, it's not I'm not taking a vacation because I'm burning and like I'm
I'm feeling burnt out. This is like something I planned a while ago
Like before I was in velar
so
um
So don't worry about that
Because if it was up to me I'd keep going I was I was literally saying earlier like oh
I'd bring my laptop with me
If I could if I had a microphone that I could bring because like my at 2020 is a is a condenser mic
So it needs to be plugged into a mixer and stuff
um
Or I just bring it with me and just like walk myself in the guest bedroom and just like yeah
I'm trying not to swear in front of my christian family
What time is it it's 12 o' seven you guys kept me talking you little bitches
You whores
Because I'm like why are people saying good night and I'm like wait I've been talking longer than eight minutes just 15
No, I'm not staying up till one
If I'm me also Bible studies. Yeah
Swap out swears with bible verses. Oh, matthew mark. Look at john
Holy judges, are you sawming me right now?
Oh my revelations
Thank goodness my family does not bible study at all the time brother
You Corinthians
You
Oh my genesis
You know lord and saints names in vain those aren't saints
How long do you throw gifts normally take to arrive it really depends on the seller sometimes like
One time I forget what one of you guys got me from like amazon
Um, but the I also can't tell if it's like it's technically from amazon most stuff is from amazon
um when you guys buy stuff, um
And it literally showed up like the next fucking day and I was like what?
Stream is never gonna end guys get over it mad. I'm unleashing infinite. Yeah, it's no jutsu
You're acting like a real Judas right now, but that's a bible character. I'm I was saying bible books
The heels don't yeah like the heels still haven't come in yet
They like recently shipped a couple days ago and those were ordered like weeks ago
Like my psalms, but it's not poms. It's psalms
Hold back the seas for a week. Yeah
I
Have this idea for a gift and I wouldn't want it to get there when you're gone. Oh understandable
That makes sense. It'll just hang out my mail room
For postal mail guys everybody relax
The mail room she keeps mails in that room
Get the gospel out of here
Like my paul's that's funny. Uh paul was an author
He was not he wrote um
He wrote axe
paul wrote axe
He also wrote more
Bumi will take it take the mail in and keep it protected
Mail mentioned on stream
Males in sheebie's room
Yeah, I'm right here
That voice changer is gonna be the death of me I swear to god
I'm gonna be able to like get the pitch just right and somebody gonna think it's gonna think it's real
and like just like take it a million miles away
and just be like
Just freak out
Finally he's back i'ma act up
Yo, what's up? It's daddy sheebie. What's up handsome?
Shabroni can shabon me
Okay, bye
Do I hear fighting in the distance
No fighting Shakira Shakira
I hear fia squeaking
Bumi are you beating up your sister?
Damn, it wasn't a strap after all
Yeah, I'm like a kendo. I just pop off my cock and I just
I just like snap it on what I need not that Ken dolls can't do that, but
I like I love how I I like jokingly made the daddy joke and some of you guys have just gone with it
Some of you guys just really love calling me daddy, but you know, it's okay. I'll accept it
We must have a different Ken dolls. Are you saying that you play the dolls you little bitch, you know, can I?
Um, see now, like I really like the visibles of
Five so now I have to end at 1215
Sorry
She be look chatters be while are they not are they're always?
I
Like all flavors of she be what can I say?
You spelt sunk cost fallacy
You put son the cost
That's sunk cost
Father she be just me except I'm like I'm a priest father
I don't think I've ever called she be mommy
It's funny because like
Strawny's intention with me was supposed to be like step on me mommy, but I don't really think I'm step on me mommy
I'm just a loser
I'm just a dork at this point when they when you see my full outfit. I'm like step on me mommy
Like I'll fucking long my life. I can't get over how long my legs are because it's very fun funny proportions
um
I
Think I'm mad at my mistress
Yeah, I got them thick thighs thick thighs say
Big sister vibes
Oh, I just got back from the office. Do you have dinner ready?
What are you talking about? You don't have dinner ready. I asked you to put the chicken out before I left for work
Some brother you are
Now you know I have to punish you. Oh, great
Yeah, I don't show the
a full body
I have legs for days
But do you want us to call him? I don't really care either way
You too could have that I'm very good at improv
You just remind me of a real person that's kind of messed up, but I forgive you what?
Your honor, I think it's mad. I'm so stick with that
I think madam is talented enough to do it all
Dom's can care about their subs. That is true
because don't like I I dom and sub relationship is all about trust and communication
And boomie yelling and running across my room
She'd be get the feet in there too. Oh, sorry on my screen. I can like see my feet, but
What is
Did you just run into the fucking trash can
You did you ran into the recycling bin. Are you okay?
You're walking around like you're
embarrassed
And boomie. What's up?
Okay, it's 1215
It's 1215. I gotta go. I'm leaving. I'm out of here. I'm out of here. I'm out of here
Bye
We're out. We're leaving
Did I press that like 12 twice? I don't know if I can open it
I need to go to bed now. It's 12 16. It's fine. I'm technically ending
It's fine. It's fine. I'm ending at 12 16. I mean 12 12 15
No, I don't like it. It bothers me
It's 12 15. I've clicked the end button at 12 15. So I'm ending at 12 15. Shut up everyone
Shut up everybody. Shut up. You're gonna trigger me. I'm triggered
I'm triggered
You're a bitch
You're a whore
Is 20 not a divisible of five
Oh
No, I can't wait for no now it's 12 17. No, I don't like it
What I'm just gonna I'm just gonna end at 12 20. Yeah
I
Just stay in particular. I just need to end
I don't know why I just have to I can't explain it. I have to end on a divisible
I just really like divisible to five
Yeah, well, I do have OCD. So yeah
No, shut up. It's not gonna become 12 30. Yes, I'm still talking to you with my ending screen. What a bit
Oh
Oh my god, my BGM is fucking. I'm sorry if I just bled your eardrums fully shit
Time to echo
Echo I need a burp really bad. I need a mute. Ha ha wait
Ha
Don't make me out till 12 21. That's not nice
Smooth jazz jumpscare
Yeah, see I'm prepared
I am prepared. I'm gonna go watch the boys. Oh my god. Wait the boys are on am I gonna go watch the boys?
I don't know. I'm kind of tired
How do you take my meds is marrow even streaming anymore, I have no idea
I don't know
Get comfy people were in there
We're in for a while and then no shut up
Tell us in the boys season four. I'll be on. No wait. I was
I was about to launch into something
I was like, I'll be honest, but no, no, no
Okay
I don't know. I'm actually concerned because it's very quiet right now. Stop stop talking to me. I'm not reading chat anymore. I'm muting myself
Goodbye
stinky
Extremely you guys are extra stinky today
So stinky go check it. Oh, it's 12 20
Okay
I love you